[Music]
[Applause]
O well hey everybody it's Wednesday
night and we're doing a paranormal show
everyone is very excited about that yeah
I feel like well it's been a while since
we've done like a whole paranormal
hasn't it I don't remember I love these
we're going to talk about Poltergeist
yeah yeah which I've seen yeah Jenny
wrote a book wrote several books on it
on the subject and U Jenny's seen it too
it's not as bad it's not as strong as it
was but every now and then it [__]
comes back we going to talk about Donnie
Decker yeah among other things yeah is
he I don't know if he's out of prison
yet I don't know I couldn't really find
any updates on what had happened to I
thought he had gotten out of prison but
I don't know what happened to him since
then try to find his
ass yeah that's the only guy that's the
only other that that's one of the few
living dudes that I believe when it
comes to
Poltergeist um he just said a lot of the
right [__] and there was just too many
damn witnesses that that first time he
was in prison the [__] Warden and all
the [__] guards they called in the
priest man [__] water was [__]
flying at the damn priest and ripping
down his cell walls and he can make it
rain in restaurants he could make it
rain inside the
house and I was like some people would
be like man how's that possible it's
[__] not Poltergeist is a poltergeist
phenomenon rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis is a fascinating
[__] I don't want to say it's an
ability because you can't really do it
at command it's a [__] side effect
it's of Consciousness somehow some kind
of quantum Consciousness he was
condensing
[__] water molecules out of the
air making that making water molecules
he's making
water and then there was like a kinetic
energy
[__] uh factor to it to it also
because it would sometimes fall up or or
sideways some of the drops things that
hit you he he [__] yeah and he kind
of had the
background of of a poltergeist [__]
Focus yeah I mean we'll get into that
it's interesting too like how um you
saying like some of the water went up
and stuff like that because that other
book and I'm not talking about this case
because we already did a whole show
about it a long time ago but the um the
book that I wrote with Steve Mara the
rdale Poltergeist that Casey
investigated in um Manchester England
yeah um they had it rain inside their
house also and they noticed that as well
that the sometimes the rain would go up
yeah which is pretty weird with Decker
was a lot of rain though you do it in
front of a bunch of people the cop well
the rale one was yeah I guess so yeah
that was like a lot of so much that they
needed an umbrella sometimes but there
were a lot of police witnesses that saw
and said they'd never see anything like
it dude the cop [__] went back home
he was just shaking he he you know he'd
never seen anything like that so it just
changed his
world uh the other other case that um
that I know of off the top of my head
that I was like yeah that's the real
thing is the U the infield polter guys
case guy lion Playfair wrote a book
about it called [__] this house was
haunted although he comes out and says
it wasn't a ghost it was a poltergeist
this little girl was making it
subconscious recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis under the control of the
subconscious
mind now not everything not all the
phenomena in that case attributed to
that case is true some of the people I
think lied about what they
saw but the stuff that people agreed on
that happened had multiple witnesses
that sounds exactly like the kind of
[__] me Lois and red went through at at
Mammoth Mountain when I was a kid it's a
lot like the Enfield case but there
wasn't any voices coming out of me or
anything um I don't remember hearing any
voice at all in Mammoth now later at
Lois's house there was a voice that
tried to manifest itself just out of
thin air but I couldn't understand what
it said I ran from
it sounded like it was something
underwater kind of talking backwards
it's weird man it's weird last major
thing it did was a few years back
it pulled the top of the molding of the
[__] kitchen cabinet off and thre all
the horse statues that were up on top
there all in one Fell Swoop
boom yeah it was just when I turned my
back it did it
pow and and that was at our other house
in our old house in s threw like three
of them the statues are about this big
they were wooden some of them broke yeah
and it pulled like a Sixt Sixt piece of
molding off and the nails the there
little nails that they use for molding
it looks like almost like a glorified
tack or something or a stap those Brads
Brad I think it's called yeah those
things were [__] twisted and still
stuck in there [__] still sticking in
that piece of
molding and uh I just looked at it I
knew it was but I tried to blow it
off yeah weird all it does now is turn
the Xbox on in the middle of the night
yeah it's the main thing it does here
turn the Xbox on and it doesn't turn the
TV on because if you want like watch it
or play a game you have to turn the Xbox
on and then you have to turn the TV on
it doesn't turn the TV on though it only
turns the Xbox on and you always know
because like 3 o'clock in the morning
you go like it that little noise like it
comes on and I'm just like what the [__]
it did it as I was falling asleep Jenny
was next to me yeah a few days ago I was
worried about a bill I had to pay and it
did it yeah but it used to turn on the T
the television it used to turn at the
old house it turned on the TV like all
the time at least several times a week
yeah in the living room yeah but then
occasionally it would turn on the
television in our bedroom we'd wake up
and the [__] TV was on yeah usually
it was the living room but a few times
it was the bedroom one yeah cuz it would
light up like you know what I mean it be
like what the [__] ring the doorbell at
night open the garage door at night yeah
I think that was the freakiest thing
yeah it like ringing the doorbell yeah
cuz that well I was freaked out by that
because I thought it was a person and
I'm like who the [__] is ringing the
doorbell at [__] 4 in the morning
that's never good but it was it was
anybody there so it was like it was
pretty [__] freaky but if you want to
hear my whole case Jenny wrote a book
about it based upon it me Lois and red
gave our
stories um my cousin Wesley gave his
story but his story changed a little bit
he was he's uh deaf and
autistic and I had to leave some of it
out because his mom didn't want me
talking about him too much in there so
uh yeah we had to kind of tread
carefully yeah had to tread real
carefully on the west subject sometimes
there's some people who've read the book
who said well hey well couldn't couldn't
Wes have done this and that no I haven't
been able to tell you everything yet
they're all you know Lois is still
living Red's dead unfortunately I mean
Wes is still living R still alive but he
doesn't read that [__] yeah his reading
comprehension isn't very good yeah um so
maybe once she's gone maybe we'll I'll
go into a little bit more detail but
um the uh red remembered more of it than
I did I remember a lot of than you time
was your uncle you know yeah and there
were some major ones that I'd forgotten
about like I forgot that I threw a knife
I forgot that it rearranged the Matchbox
cars put them out on the floor [__]
in a pattern I forgot about that part um
it did a bunch of stuff that I'd
forgotten about but it didn't do it at
Mammoth they did it at loa's house when
we got later when you got home later
when we got home it followed us yeah cuz
it was just a a phenomenon it was
manifesting from me I couldn't control
it yeah because I mean if you I mean
probably most of you guys know CU you've
been here a long time but yeah yeah it
happened to Tom when he was 12 or 13
right yeah and it was not even at your
house at least at first it was at like
just some vacation Lodge that you'd
never been to before like he went there
and all this crazy [__] started
happening I knew something bad was going
to happen there and the uh when we were
driving there up through the mountains I
said man this kind of reminded me of the
beginning of The Shining so I was
starting to have a feeling of dread and
the hood flew up on the car [__] red
we were we were on the side of a damn
Mountain on the side of a cliff he hit
the brakes and got out there and and he
did it had open but he didn't couldn't
didn't and it flew open and everything
and he had no idea how it could have
because it was a latch with a safety
mechanism and it never did it
again but he drove and it was snowing
you're doing that [__] Tom yeah it was
weird and it was weird when it happened
it felt like I'd been [__] like I
jumped out of my [__] felt like I
jumped out of my skin when it happened
it's weird yeah I can imagine yeah and
then soon as we got there I threw my
bags on the [__] bed and went back to
the car to get my other bag when I came
back my the bed that I have I saw
something moving on the bed it was
opened and [__] had been scattered out
and I saw a sock come to a halt rolled
up pair of socks and I looked at it and
said it must have fell
over but it I had a weird feeling it it
didn't fall over it was going through it
or trying to
unpack he was trying to help you out
yeah later on that night I started doing
[__] I hear moving things inside the
room picked up the damn telephone
receiver next to me it dropped it see
that was like for me that was like super
creepy like that whole first night that
you described that you heard like the
the um the hangers in the closet like
jingling together yeah there was nothing
on the hangers it was empty CL and then
like you heard like the phone pick up
and go back down on the dropped about
you kids that you know the phone used to
have to use to set it on the Cradle you
know what I mean and uh I cuz you know
what if I was in hotel room and I heard
that like behind me I think I would
[__] was in hotel room you were in a
sh I know I'm just saying but if I was
in a place like that you were in a condo
and heard the phone do that behind me I
[__] yeah I I would freak out the
phone was weird it had had I think it
had a phone upstairs and a phone
downstairs and it had the little lights
run across the bottom like you yeah like
a hotel phone like a hotel phone it was
like that like so you could call out and
so you could call out and you call the
[__] main office and [__] right and I
heard that receiver pick up and fall
and I was afraid to look it was dark in
there I'd have been afraid to look too
I'm like yeah I'm just going to pretend
that didn't happen I waited for like
three or 4 seconds and I [__] looked
over there cuz it was it was on the uh
the right nightstand oh the one on when
you're laying there there the one on the
right hand side there's one on either
side of the bed and I looked over there
and the phone was there I could barely
see it but there was nobody standing
there I felt like someone was watching
me there can you imagine like if
somebody was standing there oh my God
that would be horrible yeah and I'd also
heard something [__] D getting drugg
across the floor
you he but I couldn't see
anything sounded like
Furniture but I didn't see anything move
it's
weird Mr demigod said I love topics like
this yeah a lot of people have been
looking forward to doing because this is
going to be like a whole yeah
Extravaganza hopefully I don't think
we've covered any of these cases before
like I said um we've probably talked
about the dawn Decker case like off and
on I thought we had done a whole show
about it but I searched and we hadn't I
was like I find that hard to believe so
we must have like brought it up on some
other shows and talked about it but I
don't think I've talked about any of
these other cases on here and if we have
oh well we're just like repeating [__]
it's all right um Allison Wonderland
says uh I'm loving the mustache Tom and
be yeah I like it
too it's just it's funny cuz when I I I
knew you for a long time and you had no
facial hair yeah and uh so then you
decided to grow it and I was like we're
like oh okay well we'll see how that
looks and I'm like oh it looks really
good like it's kind of surprised me that
it looked really good and he told me the
other day somebody that you know at
Starbucks at Starbucks yeah and the girl
work at Starbuck she didn't know you
before like so she's only know you with
the facial hair seen and he showed her
pictures of him from like a few years
ago when he still had hair and like no
facial hair and she's like what the [__]
like she thought weird she thought it
was super weird because she's only seen
you like that but and I and I said and I
said not good she goes no she you better
like that you look better you look good
both ways look better bald with beard I
mean it did take me a little while to
get used to you looking like this
because like I said I knew you for so
many years you know with hair when you
meet me like this you expect me to look
like this I guess that's what I mean so
it's like when you look different but
it's like yeah I met you with hair and
with no facial hair you met me with
blonde hair yeah I think well no you
know what when I first met you you had
black hair and then like not too long
after I met you I think you bleached it
but I'm pretty sure you had black hair
when I met I went from black to to
blonde Almost White yeah cuz your
natural hair color is just a really
really dark it's almost black it's like
a really really dark yeah brown but you
had it it was black when I met you but
then not too long after that you
bleached it so and then kept it bleach
for a little but mostly I've known you
with like with black hair you know what
I mean yeah most of the time I think I
got a picture of me with blonde hair you
probably go ahead I'll find
it Danny ring said what's a polter guy's
favorite genre of porn [__] yeah yeah
yeah that's
that is a good one he's got all the dad
jokes yeah
a that's a dad joke but yeah so what we
wanted to talk about this and I can't
remember it was it Zach or was it
somebody I can't remember like who um uh
suggested this topic but I thought it
was a good topic it was when we were
talking about Poltergeist cases it might
have been when we were talking about the
um Latoya ammon's case which was a few
months back um and somebody said oh we
should talk about some cases uh some
Poltergeist cases where the focus was
not a kid because most of the time the
focus is like a kid or like an
adolescent you know what I mean yeah
yeah that's him with the blonde hair
yeah standing next with car Fisher with
Carrie
Fisher with a cardboard carry
F that's another one [__]
funny [__] funny he like something
out of Duran Duran that's not me by the
way no no that's that's his that's his
old
girlfriend
that's a really old picture yeah it's
200 uh 15 no no was older than that 201
10 2011 it must have been because we
started we started dating in 2011 yeah
so 2010 so it must have been 2010 or or
early 2011 cuz I think we started going
out like mid 2011 yeah it's hard to
believe that was uh [__] almost 14
years ago it's not [__] crazy [__]
crazy it doesn't seem like it seems it
seems like yesterday you still mad about
that
you still mad about that I like that
girl Jenny was like do not go out with
that girl that girl's bad and I'm
thinking I like yeah but I've had whole
girlfriends I lived with that were about
two or three times as bad as this you
I'm from a different world than Jen well
you know she was bad but they were all
bad I was used to that he he liked his
bad hoes
man well and the thing and the thing
about it too is that you didn't really
give that much you didn't really care
that much you were just kind of like
I'll bang her for a while I'm going to
hit yeah then I'll just move on to
something else it was was like ayor belt
it was it was like ayor you wer real
serious about about it did not care so
he didn't really get I was just
expecting it to be temporary yeah you
know he's just like I'm just going to
have a good time whatever like 13 year L
13 years later we're still living
together I was like [__] I might as well
marry this chick yeah yeah fck great I
told him I told him at mannequins cuz uh
we had went back to mannequins last
Friday and we Haden been for a long time
and Heather our bartender she was like
oh my my God look at you guys you
haven't been here in Forever she's like
oh my God you're a married couple now
cuz she saw it on Facebook and
um I told Tom later I was like yeah I
was like to be honest I'd actually given
up on you I thought you were never GNA I
just stopped thinking about it I thought
you were never G to ask me I was just
like oh well I guess that's not
happening actually I asked her I asked
you [__] man where you putting all this
[__] [__] private [__] probably
about six seven years ago I asked you
were in a bad mood you're like nah [__]
that I thought you were teasing me I
don't think you were I didn't think you
were serious no I was serious I didn't
think you were serious I was okay we
just get married then she's like a [__]
that I okay I think sh yourself in the
foot no I think there was some different
context going on because I would have
remembered if you'd like seriously asked
me I don't remember I don't remember
exactly yeah so I think it was like some
kind of context like we were probably
having a fight or something
yeah and he said something about it and
I'm like [__] that you're just [__]
with me yeah they remember me with
blonde hair we did shows some of the
shows yeah that's right that wasn't the
same time I used to go blonde every now
and then every now and then yeah that
wasn't that wasn't the time that wasn't
that time that cuz that was like before
we started that was years before we
started doing the show I still got some
in there I would used that damn [__]
Splat bleach yeah I used that a couple I
still got some in there [__] unopened
ready to go yeah I was thinking man if I
could [__] grow my hair out about a
quarter of an inch half inch and [__]
Dy that [__] [__] damn near White I'd
have that Rob howford look like back in
the [__]
80s there you go the white head the
short real short white hair I don't know
if it' look good though I don't know it
might not with a black beard well no
you'd have to do the beard yeah you'd
have to let the beard grow gray or yeah
just [__] shave the
yeah so I use that Just For Men Just For
Men Just For Men what'll happen if you
put it on a woman will she like turn
into a [__] pumpkin or something put
that [__] on her Bush
man it'll [__] shave 20 years off of
I I don't have a bush mhm but um but
yeah a lot of people don't nowadays it's
just easier Tammy says do you believe
that Poltergeist have something to do
with hormones and that is why it usually
comes around when the kids are going
through puberty there was actually a
paper in a semi scientific yeah uh
Journal uh in which I believe it was two
Italian I think I brought it up in my
book but I can't remember their names
off hand these two Italian scientist
and that's kind of what they were
positing yeah I think it's a factor one
of the major probably that's probably
like the most likely time rspk could
could happen to a young person going
through hormonal changes like that
because now they're able to re release
certain amount of tensions fuing on a
psychic level evidently and a bunch of
tensions building up in them they're
becoming an adults so there's conflicts
between I think it's kind of like
children
I think CH might be getting ahead of the
subject well not really because children
don't really have
agency so they it's kind of like learned
helplessness and if they're in a
situation where they have to accept
certain truths that aren't true in other
words [__] the adults are lying to
them when they get intelligent enough
when puberty happens they start to
realize that no I can do [__] without
these people I can do my own things but
they can't there's a conflict they're
still too young so the subconscious
starts acting out not the cuz they
they're getting in trouble yeah
so the physical body is under wraps but
the [__] this's just say I the soul
is running wild basically it's the
[__] the soul of the
subconscious it's moving objects
throwing a [__] fit or it's uh
pretending to be a [__] artificial
bad guy to to maybe like get the family
to bind together against a common enemy
or to entertain the family hold them
together that kind of [__]
well and your theory is um and from what
I've seen this kind of does hold up is
that uh it actually works better if you
think it's an outside entity if you
believe it's an outside entity because
in your case particularly it stopped
when you realized that it was you well I
suspected that you suspected that it was
you doing because I thought it was
reading my mind it was moving objects I
was thinking about cuz while you thought
it was a ghost or an outside entity then
it was doing all this crazy [__] but the
second you were like well maybe this is
me doing it yeah then it sto then it
kind of stopped I told red I said I said
I think this thing can read my mind and
he goes why you think that and I said
that object it just moved I was just
thinking about that object yeah he's
like really I said yeah it could read my
mind and that started to [__] scare
me but then it kept doing
it and I said maybe it's not reading my
mind maybe I'm doing it yeah so then I
said I'm going to make it move these
objects and it stopped it yeah so like
some there's some kind of fail safe yeah
that only lets it happen when you think
it's when you're not aware of it or you
don't have any didn't go away it stopped
moving things instantly but didn't go
away instantly I still felt it watching
me right and it still happened like I
said periodic sporadically yeah like um
you know in the last few years
especially when when we started working
on the book like in 2017 or 2018 or
whatever that was like so we were
talking about the case all the time and
talking to red and Lois on the phone and
all this other kind of stuff so um kind
of relived it yeah so then it kind of
ramped back up again a little bit Zach
says is the entity case in here too um
no because we did a whole show about
that like a while back I think we talked
about it on one of our first shows
because we talked about the movie and
the actual case and how they compared
but we might have done an update I
thought we had done an update where we
just talked about the Doris bther case
didn't we yeah like more recently we did
well and we did one on the hernand
yeah but it's just kind like yeah but
this one like I said we wanted to focus
on ones where um where the focus of the
of the Poltergeist activity was an adult
which young adult unusual Deckard was a
younger adult I think yeah and one of
the other cases on here too uh was a
younger adult as well but like I said
usually and I kind of feel like almost
all of the cases cuz I wrote a book
several years ago called the UN in hand
that was all about Poltergeist cases
like all the ones I could dig up and um
I I don't know what the percentage is
off hand but I would say probably like
at least like 85 to 90% of the cases the
focus the suspected Focus was almost
always a teenager or like someone going
through puberty yeah almost always it's
a way of acting out and avoiding it
getting in trouble that's that's what it
is yeah it you have plausible
deniability like you can wreck [__] and
you know and it's like well it's not me
doing it it's it's this thing or burn
[__] didn't happen in my case but
pyrokinesis is the same thing and do you
know what's weird is that pyrokinesis is
almost overwhelmingly it's almost
overwhelmingly a girl a girl sounds like
it yeah like an adolescent girl I think
there was one case where it was a boy
but it's like almost all of the cases
that I wrote about if it was Fire
Starting Poltergeist it was always a
girl making a fire making fires never
occurred to me we were never afraid of
that right in the in the in our case but
had somebody mentioned hey man this
thing might start a fire it probably
might probably would have done it
because that would be easy to do because
it can move large objects just [__]
quickly and it evidently teleport
them uh I I guess it's the only way some
of those objects could have got in that
room it'd be teleported in
there it'd be nothing to just agitate
molecules those are tiny just get those
molecules move real fast you're making
friction and heat and it'll
boom it'll [__]
ignite and pyrokinetic people that's how
it's described just a a burn spot kind
of like somebody hitting it with a
magnifying glass a brown spot will
appear on a wall yeah like on the
wallpaper smoke [__] you're right
like like somebody would had a
magnifying glass to it and what's funny
is that it's always timed perfectly
which just sounds like everything with
the PO everything's timed perfectly like
the fire starts just as you see it just
as you're walking into a room it never
happens when you're not all when you're
never happens when you're not around to
stop it it's always happening when
you're around to stop
it I mean there were a couple of cases
that wrot about that were old where you
know um but I don't think anybody got
killed but it's like sometimes like an
old barn or something like that would
burned down completely so there was that
Ben said it's Stephen King's fault
because a fire starter although there
were a lot of cases of that before I
think he got the idea from the
Poltergeist cases that had happened
previously because there were some going
back to like the 18th century people
always point out fiction like Star Wars
sorry that's my phone God damn it
[__] phone Star Wars with the force
and then [__] um Stephen King with
all of his
[__] uh pyrokinetic people and
psychokinetic people and people that see
ghosts and [__] they didn't make any of
that up during the 70s the California
University Systems took that [__] very
seriously they had a whole Paras
pychological
Department it was respected by other
scientific departments cuz they they
weren't faking anything they were trying
to see if it was possible and they they
they did take some of these cases
seriously and they were trying to
theorize well what is happening in
physics to you know now it's called like
[__] non-locality and Quantum
Consciousness you know and they got top
guys like steuart amov working on that
and uh steuart hammer and he's an
anesthesiologist that is into
Consciousness and who's the other guy
guy [__] um that waser pen Roger
Penrose yeah who was a physicist he's a
big physicist and um they're going
they're they're talking about things
that would make all this plausible which
leads me to believe that they've that
I've seen it I know it's real so they
figured it out if you ask me they
figured it out just they can't prove it
yet yeah I mean it makes sense like the
the tack that they're coming at at from
I must say microtubules in the brain
that part of your brain you're not a
you're not a digital computer you're
analog
and part of the processes that are
happening inside the neurons of your
brain are quantum it's Quantum
computation and it's not supposed to
happen in a warm wet
environment but they're saying that some
of the materials inside the dent inside
the [__] like where the dendrites are
there's all these
microtubules that seem to be made out
of uh proteins that act as like a a meta
material that photons can [__] flow
fire down them at basically the speed of
light so each brain cell has got
millions and millions of these little
things with photons running through
there well then when you start dealing
with these subatomic particles you start
dealing with quantum entanglement and
once that happens [__] it Newtonian
physics is out the window certain parts
of your Consciousness are not is not
Newtonian it's outside normal
SpaceTime which means that if you're
part of it is outside normal SpaceTime
it could do things like cheat so it's a
way of cheating cheating
physics using Consciousness sounds
[__] crazy but they believe it's
plausible and I've seen it well I mean
the universe is pretty weird yeah the
universe is much weirder than you think
it is now the whole thing about [__]
George Lucas and the force these Jedi
and [__] he didn't invent that either
that was all Buddhism and Germanic
philosophy kind of merged together we
have fiction people who write fiction
they're not inventing me where yeah you
just get ideas from other and I got a
lot of ideas from like non-fiction from
like science books I read and like weird
cases and [__] I got a lot of ideas from
that kind of stuff evidently the
Buddhist and some Shinto people over in
Japan have back like you know I think it
was 1700s to the 1400s around that era
there were some people that had observed
Poltergeist activity and young girls
that were servant girls and they
describe it exactly like a modern polter
guys case yeah I wrote about some really
old ones like that yeah they had a
samurai guy who's of the Samurai class
investigating it
and the girl can make pots and pants
jump around and
dance and could and it would rip silk
Fabric and and rip the Paper
Walls when nobody was around did weird
[__] like that did things behind your
back and they homed in on this girl who
was about 13 who worked there and he
thought it was a an imbalance of yin and
yang an imbalance of guess good and
positive energy negative and positive
energy in and his uh and his his advice
was to fire that girl so they fired her
and it stopped that's what they usually
tell yeah said fire that girl and and
she left and it stopped cuz there have
been I read about several cases too
where it was like a a teenage servant
girl that was in the house that they
thought was causing the
[__] Sebastian and know she wasn't doing
it with her hands because it would
happened while her hands were in plain
view yeah something would happen
Sebastian says in my investigations I
found that there was Poltergeist
activity or infestation in properties
that had different residents and
sometimes empty houses what happened to
Tom could be a different or similar
phenomena I don't know I don't know he's
getting it well just saying that just
saying that it might not necessarily
just be from a single person it might
just be from some kind of he said he saw
some in uh empty houses and houses that
it had more than one Poltergeist cases
aren't just the focus not just the kid
it's the family it's
the it's a group
Synergy it seems when you have a
certain when you have a certain group of
people around they can their their
effects on each other can cause it to
happen cause it to happen from that kid
something didn't happen when I was back
at home it only happened when I was with
Lois and red only happened when we were
together for that period
yeah so it had something to do with the
family Dynamic had something to do with
the family Dynamics yeah yeah that does
seem to be the case yeah because the
weird thing about it is that sometimes
like there'll be cases where they
thought oh this teenage girl or whatever
was the focus of it so they sent them
away to boarding school and then like
nothing happens when they're out of that
environment because what I mean what
we're saying is that there has to be
some kind of synergy between the other
people around the environment that
they're in and maybe once they're out of
that environment it doesn't trigger the
[__] in this case in my case I didn't
want to go back home I wanted to live
with Lois of red and West I didn't
really want to go back home yeah so this
was in some way some way a binding this
together yeah that's that's that's what
I believe it was yeah it was like a
bonding thing almost me and red [__]
against the
ghost yeah we called it a blast cuz we
need a Cod word so nobody know what we
were talking about they never know what
we were talking about we're talking
about a blo you see that blow did it
threw that and this and that yeah
although I think if people heard the
whole context they would know what you
were talking about yeah we were
goofing red was [__] he was Brave man
for a dude who was he was young as in
his 20s and had never really seen
anything up to this point [__] never
really even been anywhere just some
California guy yeah he was [__] brave
enough to go downstairs by himself in
the [__] dark to investigate like
after they heard like weird [__] no
they heard that chain pop on the [__]
door but he didn't see it he didn't see
it on his way back up next morning I saw
it he's he went downstairs and said uh
that last room the the beds pushed up
against the door I can't open door from
the inside from the inside nobody was in
there and I was [__] spooked that bed
was way a lot made out of it was a
[__] bunk bed and I was just a big
chilling effect on me it pushed it from
inside he go yeah I can't open the door
and I was up on sleeping upstairs on the
couch by that
time I was just Big Chill I was like oh
oh I can feel it watching me yeah yeah
he's reliving it m now now that we're
talking about it like shit's probably
going to happen tonight I was like how
much you I bety you $5 that the Xbox
comes on by itself maybe now it is
possible that I mean I guess that Pooky
could be hitting it with her nose or
something no I was awake when I was
awake falling asleep and Happ she was WR
but yeah I heard it goink yeah it makes
a little like a little chiming noise
like like when it comes on yeah looked I
saw the little Xbox symbol was on and I
reached forward and grabbed the control
and turn it off she wasn't anywhere near
that truck okay so that was the only
that was the only explanation I could
think of is that PO Pooky went and like
poked it or something Electronics that's
easy to mess with yeah that's true that
does happen a lot but yeah so we were
kind of interested to explore some of
these cases where the focus was not what
you would normally see in that kind it's
like not an adolescent you know what I
mean so so like these are some of these
are young adults some of them are older
like
elderly uh so there's that as well I
think I have five cases but you know
we'll we'll just see how it goes when we
talk about it because I know that uh
this is one of Tom's favorite subjects
yeah so he might have a lot of input on
some of these because I think the Don
Decker case is really the only one of
these that you're familiar with
maybe you know yeah what I was reading I
think the Don I think the Don Decker
case is the only one of these that you
might be real familiar with the other
ones you might not yeah so we'll get
your insights on other stuff unless you
dug up anything anything any new stuff I
at one time I you know I was totally up
to date on DOD Decker and everything
that I you know what I looked for any
updates and there really wasn't anything
like I said last I heard he got out of
prison and that was maybe
200 17 18 something like that but it's
like maybe later but I haven't heard
anything about him since he went to pris
because his boss hired him to uh burn
down the business that they worked at
they were going to split the [__]
insurance money he got five years for
that arson
yeah but yeah his boss hired him to do
it it's not like it was doing it to
somebody who didn't want it to happen
just insurance fraud yeah that's what
that was I don't know if the boss got
any prison time probably did maybe so
but I know he did but yeah so poor guy I
kind of feel bad for him they did a um
Unsolved Mysteries about him back back
in the '90s that's where I first heard
about the case actually yeah so these
cases I actually just did them in like
chronological
order uh so the first one I want to talk
about is from
1962 and this is usually just known as
the Indianapolis Poltergeist case or
I've seen it called the Beck Poltergeist
case not that Beck uh that was just
their last name now the interesting
thing about this case something I
thought was interesting was that this is
um three women in a house it was a
grandma a mom and the daughter now the
daughter whose name was Linda was
actually 133 so she was like the prime
kind of age for a poltergeist Focus
however um no uh account of this case
that I've read has anything to do with
her there's like she wasn't even present
for a lot of the stuff and it didn't
seem like any of the activity was
focused around her the way a lot of
times it obviously is they actually
thought that the focus in this case was
probably the older woman who was 61 at
the time um or or possibly the middle
the middle one who was 32 I believe but
um no account says that they thought it
was the 13-year-old girl so that's why
this is kind of unusual there was a
13-year-old girl but they didn't think
she was the center of anything so as I
said this happened in 1962 now so this
this is three generations of women
living in one house they' lived there
for uh quite a while I believe it wasn't
like they just moved in or anything like
that uh but very suddenly uh this was in
March of 1962 it was a little past uh 10
at night uh renate Beck who was the
32-year-old woman um she was at home her
daughter Linda was at home she was 13
like I said and then she had a mom named
Lena gcki who was widowed and she was 61
now Linda the 13-year-old girl she was
in the living room just hanging out
watching TV or whatever the two older
women are in the kitchen just like
cleaning up or whatever and then all of
a sudden this glass beer mug that had
been in the sink like lifted out of the
sink and then kind of like went behind a
flower pot like that was right there
like on the sink or whatever they saw
this yeah they were both in there all
right yeah and they just saw that happen
um so they're like what um okay what
what the [__] but they you know as you
would they had never seen anything weird
happen to this house before like I said
they lived here for quite a while so
they just thought oh well there has to
be some explanation for that maybe it
was an earthquake or maybe a big truck
went by or something like that like they
just kind of came up with something like
that Jen saw the remote fly off the
table with some friends were over at the
time that
happen and U they were just kind of
stunned they they couldn't believe that
that it happened yeah yeah and I didn't
notice that it happened until I saw them
and I was like oh okay yeah I guess that
did happen well I mean you don't you're
not expecting it for one thing and then
and then immediately your brain starts
trying to come up with like a rational
explanation like the first thing I
thought like I saw the the remote go
flying the first thing I thought was did
I kick the coffee table yeah I knew I
didn't kick the coffee a glass coffee
table I knew I didn't kick the coffee
table but that was just like the first
thing I thought oh I must have kicked
the coffee table without realizing it
and like sent the thing flying we tried
to reproduce it and it didn't make the
same sound or anything but you know so I
thought about it for a second and then I
looked over at our friends over there
and they were just like their eyes were
like this and they were like looking at
me and they're like did did you just see
that happen and I was like oh okay I
thought I just kicked the table but I
guess not
I didn't yeah it's weird and we did try
to reproduce it like I said and we
couldn't back in the day i' have [__]
jumped out of my skin now it's just kind
be tearing my hair out of how that
happened why how did it do that what
what did it mean what's it trying to
tell me that kind of
stuff but we can I can get I can I can
get Beyond it a lot easier now like okay
it just does it just does things yeah
and it's not like I said at at this
point when I saw this happen in the
house we had already discussed it to a
great degree and I had already pretty
much come to the conclusion the same
conclusion that you did that it's like
it was a manifestation of you so it
didn't really scare me it had already
tore down that yeah it surprised me yeah
but um you know cuz I obviously I wasn't
expecting it I was like oh that was kind
of neat imagine it doing that every five
or 10 minutes right that's what it's
like when it's really kicked off and a
lot of it's happening in rooms that
you're not in you hear it happening in
there you go in there and you find a
[__] ruus you Furniture tipped over
and [__] can you describe the Ruckus
yeah it's making patterns on the ground
with [__] hand towels and [__] yeah
making happy faces and crap yeah that
was pretty weird [__] is freaky yeah
Danny rling said a TV show revolving
around all the Paranormal cases that
college parapsychology departments
handled would be Stellar as [__] to se
yeah I agree that would actually be a
good show where they took it like more
seriously and not just like the stupid
Ghost Hunter shows yeah like an evolved
version of the show of Haunting they
don't the universities don't have have
those departments anymore that's problem
yeah but I mean you could go back to
when they right I think there's one or
two colleges left in the United States
that still have a parapsychology
department but military is still
interested in it yeah I mean you know
yeah did project Stargate under a couple
different names it's funny because I've
just started last night I just started
rewatching um Stephen King's rose red um
because I've been wanting to rewatch
that for a l I haven't seen that [__]
since it was on TV like back in 2002 and
so somebody I was on Facebook the other
day and somebody said oh my God somebody
they finally put it on Hulu because I
was just looking to watch it the other
day and I couldn't find the [__]
thing and then it's like somebody just
put it on Hulu you know Hulu just put it
on Hulu obviously so uh I was like
woohoo so you know Tom went to bike
night last night I said well [__] I'm
just going to sit down and with some
snacks and like watch this [__] so I'm I
watched the first two parts but I
haven't watched the third one yet I
might do like a thing about it for um
for um my scare Salon Channel but the
but it's interesting because in that uh
show in that series The Woman who's like
the main person she's like in the
parapsychology department and her
college is in the process of getting rid
of the parapsychology department so
they're all like making fun of her so
she's like hoping if she gets her little
ghost hunting team together and they go
to Rose Red and like she gets proof then
she'll be able to like keep her job you
know what I mean so that's what it
remind that's why it reminded me of that
then says maybe Duke University so I
don't I don't know I think it is Duke
University is one of the ones it might
be the only one that's left that still
has parasitology I thought there were
two but I remember back in the day in
California the big one from what I
remember I think I think it was Lois
that told me it was uh UCLA they had it
pretty yeah yeah yeah they had one it
was like one of the main ones in the
world
yeah I mean it's an interesting field of
study you know what I mean Lois if you
kept it LO Lois worked for the damn
Observatory for Dr Penner his name
[__] what was it Palomar University I
think is what it was called yeah and
Palomar Palomar Observatory what's where
l worked she worked by for a guy named
Dr Penner she knew Carl
San and uh Foy [__] she yeah she
told she told the uh Dr Penner about it
and he blew her off he like oh that's
[__] crazy he came back three or four
day three or four days later he goes no
no no I'm sorry yeah what you're talking
about is Poltergeist that's where we
first heard the word yeah and he goes so
one of my
colleagues says that that's a real
phenomenon he works and he's a
parapsychologist and he must have been
talking about UCLA cuz they were all
kind of that's all California
stuff but uh that's when we that's when
the first time I'd ever heard the word
polter and low told us that story couple
weeks after it happened right I said
okay Poltergeist that's what it
was yeah Michael ciki says I feel like I
witnessed a paranormal uh event I was
sleeping and as I was waking up I felt
something blowing on my neck and when I
opened my eyes black clouds went into
the ceiling o that's [__] creepy
again I would probably [__] a brick Zach
says oh [__] A scripted drama show about
a Paras psychology department would be
the [__] I agree that actually would be
a really good sh I'd watch
it um yes they're talking about rose red
uh rose red is also on YouTube was it
really I couldn't find it on there
before because I was looking for it like
a few months ago because I wanted to cuz
I had just done over on my scares laon
Channel I did um Stephen King Storm of
the Century and I was like oh man [__] I
should do rose red because I remember
really liking that and I couldn't find
it anywhere so I was really excited when
somebody told me it was on Hulu cuz I
was like well [__] I'm so I watched the
first part last and most of the second
part last night so I'll probably do it
for on my other channel but yeah so
it'll take me a while to like watch the
rest of it and like make a video about
it but yeah um yeah let me see oh there
was something else I wanted to see oh
Camp guy said surreal estate is a new
show about a real estate agency that
specialized in haunted houses and
selling them that's pretty
awesome
um
uh but yeah okay so can we let's get
back to this because I've only talked
about like one yeah we got they got a
lot of [__] to yeah we got a lot of [__]
to cover like I said I do I do want your
input on stuff it's like we can't get
too much off topic or we'll be here all
night and actually they're doing um well
I I don't think it'll take this long but
they're doing um maintenance on our
Wi-Fi yeah uh starting at midnight yeah
EST so this can't go on long so we can't
well I mean we still have like left well
like 4 hours so it's all right but yeah
they they told us it might shut off
after midnight because they're working
on it so yeah so uh so the two women
they see the glass mug it goes behind
the flower pot and they're just like huh
that was [__] weird or whatever but
then they kind of just like blew it off
you know like you do not too long after
that though about 20 minutes later both
of them hear this big crash like coming
from upstairs now at this point they're
not thinking paranormal at this like
like I said you wouldn't uh renate which
I guess is how you pronounce her name uh
she thought well somebody broke into the
house there had been like a rash of
robberies in the neighborhood so she
thought oh well the person that's
robbing the [__] is like you know is in
here now so the two older women they go
upstairs um to find out what's going on
but nobody's up there they did find out
what the crash uh what the crash was
though it was this big huge Crystal bowl
that had been on a bookshelf up there uh
it was completely broken but they
couldn't figure out how it had gotten so
far away from the shelf that it was on
cuz it was like several feet away from
the shelf that it had been on and it was
all like busted so they thought that was
pretty weird later on that same evening
uh an ashtray which was also made of
glass um flew across the living room and
broke and then another piece of Crystal
it was all the the glass and crystal in
the house like kind of jump jumed off a
shelf and also broke now at this point
the family is like uh [__] this [__] and
they went and stayed in a hotel cuz you
know at least they didn't like hang out
cuz you know all this [__] shit's
happen in their house they're like yeah
we're going to go stay in a hotel so
they come back the next
day now nothing had apparently broken
while they were gone because everything
kind of looked the same as it
had but they hadn't been back in the
house for that long but before pretty
much most of the glass and crystal items
in the house just started like flying
off shelves and breaking um in several
rooms simultaneously they said um it was
just like one thing after
another so they didn't really know what
to do at this stage so Renee calls uh a
couple of her friends she knew this guy
named uh Emil NOA and his wife like I
think she had been his um like she had
worked for him like in the past but they
were still like friends she called the
cops also so the cops came to the house
everybody the friends came to the house
and the cops came to the house so the
first cop gets there his name was uh
John Mullen he was a sergeant and uh
obviously he did not buy that this was
uh paranormal in any way shape or form
so he looks around the house you know
there's broken [__] everywhere and he
said oh well maybe you guys were playing
your stereo too loud and it was sound
waves that caused all of this stuff to
come off the [__] and break so they're
like um bro uh all we have is this dinky
little record player which doesn't even
work we don't have a big stereo system
we don't have big speakers we don't have
nothing like that so it's just like I I
don't know what to tell you it's like we
weren't playing the stereo too loud so
another cop shows up his name is Ray
Patton and uh so he's kind of looking
around downstairs and then there's this
big huge crash again from upstairs
and then they all go up there to see
what it was and it was another glass
object it was like a glass Swan and this
was in the daughter's room and this had
kind of also flown off a shelf and
broken nobody was in the room at the
time that this happened
apparently now this same
cop also uh claimed later that he saw
something kind of uh extraordinary like
while they were showing him around the
house so we got a police witness yeah
well at least two there were two cops at
the house and the friends like saw
something too and I'm going to get into
that so um renate says to the cop
because there's broken [__] everywhere
like I said so she's like there's this
mirror um that was up there and it was
broken and she said that got broken
because this glass ashtray flew off the
nightstand and smashed into it and then
she says well I have these this set of
crystal glass that were like a family
heirloom or something like that and I
was really afraid they were going to get
broken uh they would they had all been
on display in the room now three of them
were already broken so she was had
already broken like in the Poltergeist
activity so she was like freaking out so
she's like for some reason I thought
like to protect the last three she put
like a hat over them oh yeah that prot
you know what I mean what it's like she
didn't know what else to do I guess um
and so she lifts the Hat up and she says
see I put them under a hat you know what
I mean cuz I like I said I don't know
what she was thinking but she probably
wouldn't what would you do you know so
he's like okay so they all go out in the
hall and when the cop the cop was the
last one in line and when he's leaving
the room one of the glasses from that
was that had been underneath the hat
like hit him in the back yeah was the
Hat still there huh was the Hat still
sitting there yeah so it went through
the Hat yeah yeah and then it broke like
it hit his back really hard and then it
broke yeah exactly the kind of [__] that
we were seeing exactly like that yeah it
either passes through matter or it
teleports might just teleport in motion
halfway across the room I'm not sure
some of the [__] that seemed awful odd
you'd look at it you'd see it look at an
object next thing you know it was
halfway across the room flying straight
at you and hit hit you in the chest you
didn't really see it pick up pick up off
the TA off the table and travel half the
way just it just there halfway across
the room and hit you but I don't know
I don't it's difficult to just it's
difficult to know what actual path of
the object What it Took what path it
took it just arrives you don't see it
depart it's weird yeah I mean at this
point like everyone's back was to it
like everyone's out of the room but
him to it it's almost like it can't
really move it while you're looking at
it it has to be unperceived and then it
becomes kind of like in a neutral zone
like Schrodinger's cat you're not sure
where it's located is and when you're
not looking at it it's now fair game for
that phenomena to manipulate it you
don't see it until it arrives you didn't
see it depart though you weren't looking
it's weird maybe when you see it
arriving it doesn't have a hold of it
anymore so you can't see it I I don't
know something like
that yeah I mean some of the stuff was
just moving though like chairs rocking
right you
know but it had a weird blur on the back
of it and I was as soon as I saw it
rocking I just [__] froze and ran ran
from it red was sitting there [__]
just mesmerized it had a whole stack of
[__] laundry on it and it wasn't
falling off it was
weird yeah that's freaky yeah but yeah
this this part in particular is what
kind of reminded me cuz you were saying
how stuff would teleport like or go
through objects because apparently yeah
so the cop is the last one out everyone
else is out of the room and his back is
to it so one of the glasses hits him in
the back really hard and then falls on
the floor and breaks and then a second
later there was another crash yeah and
he turned and there was another Glass
Broken But the Hat was still there and
he went over there and picked the Hat up
and that one glass was still yeah
underneath that's it that's that's a
phenomenon it's a perfect way of
describing it that that reminded me
that's like yeah it doesn't make any
[__] sense no whatever it is it's
bending the laws of physics so people
going like well how could it pick this
invisible thing picking things up it
doesn't it's almost like it's not using
any energy to do
it you know it's not
like it's not like [__] you know Luke
Skywalker trying to move the [__]
X-Wing or something it just does it
spontaneously and there doesn't seem to
be any energy involved it's just changed
location somehow and it had energy when
it
arrived it's some kind of physics we
don't understand yet some kind of weird
phenomenon probably Quantum it's quantum
physics yeah
whatever is happening is happening in a
higher spatial Dimension you're not
seeing all of it it's outside most of
what's happening I think is on in
another dimension or it's quantum
entanglement maybe you know about the
objects so your mind can influence it as
long as you're not looking at it because
when you're not looking at it it's just
potentially in one place or another
something like that I noticed that early
as a kid it doesn't move something
you're looking directly at
yeah that seems very common yeah like it
can't move it like I you know I've
written about a lot of cases and I can I
really can't think of hardly any cases
where people said they saw something
lift up off you know usually when they
saw it it was already in motion or it
was already whenever they say whenever
the the the case says I saw something
lift up and do this and do
that there are other aspects of that
case that make me question I think it's
a fraud
although sometimes it could be a real
case it's just that the person is
describing the event inaccurately they
filled in the blanks saying I saw it
lift up and but really if you probably
reviewed it back their memory they never
saw it lift up it was already in motion
when they saw it yeah when I when I saw
the remote control I didn't see it
physically lift up off the table it was
already in the air yeah because it was
now it wasn't like out of the corner of
my eye it was was just under my field of
vision cuz I was just looking like two
or 3 feet above it and it was like right
it was really right in front of me it
moved into your field of vision it yeah
like I didn't see it pick up off the
table I just saw it like in the air and
I was like what the [__] yeah you know
what I mean right it's like that every
time right like it can't move it if
you're looking directly at when I was
looking at that one pin I was backing
out of the room I'd asked it to write
something I was looking at a pen I was
backing out of the room and closing the
door and I was looking at that pin and I
was wanting to see it jump up and start
writing writing I just saw a Flash and
it was already halfway across the room
and it hit me in a
chest well that flash Might Have Been Me
blinking my eye right and as it it as
soon as my eye blinked it was now in a
neutral zone where the force that Force
could act on it and then because it was
probably trying to As Long As I was
looking at it the second my eyes closed
it was able to move it because there's
nothing that could do timing that
accurate like it's watching your eyeball
and going wait for him to Blink his eye
then I'll thr it it couldn't have been
that there wasn't enough time it was
more like it was trying to move it soon
as my eyes blinked it it started moving
it started moving yeah it's the only
explanation cuz like I said I how could
you time it I don't necessarily think
it's an
intelligence it's no it's a subconscious
it's an intelligence it's just not your
waking into not yeah but like not the
way people would think of that it's the
same thing that controls the characters
in your dreams and those
that's I think that's a good way of
putting those characters do things to
you that surprise you and they say
things to you that surprise you and they
come up with your own [__] and some of
them even attack you that's why I'm
scared of this
thing it's you but it's a different
version of you it's it's running all
them puppets I mean I guess I don't
worry about it because it's you but then
I think to myself yeah but what if you
got really mad wouldn't be me to be a
subconscious version right but it's just
but it's still you it's still an aspect
of you and it's like what if you got so
mad that you just like [__] lost your
[__] [__] and it started doing stuff
that hurt me or hurt you I know that's
what I'm worried about or something well
Donnie deard said it grabbed him around
the throat and lifted him up and shook
him like a rag doll and threw him on the
ground and I don't doubt it I don't
doubt it yeah I mean somebody saw him
lift up like yeah we'll get to that
there were several witnesses that saw
that [__] yeah like I said I'm pretty
skeptical about this stuff but if
everybody kind of SE how could you be
skeptical you've seen it no I know but
I'm just saying certain aspects I'm not
sure but I'm I'm just saying that if
just some random [__] said oh I
saw this that and the other it's like my
my first instinct is to like not believe
them or think that they misperceived it
but the more witnesses you have that'd
be like yeah I saw that [__] and they're
you know and they tell you the same
story even when they're not like
together and stuff then I'm kind of more
inclined to think that maybe there's
something to it you know well now you
got a little taste of it you haven't
even seen it way as strong
yeah when I was that [__] was [__]
Stellar yeah you'd make make you a
believer in [__] 20 minutes yeah like
I said it's weird but because we had
already talked about it so much when I
saw it it didn't scare me yeah but
you'll have a whole [__] crisis like
how could this be they say this isn't
true this is not supposed to be
happening but I know that this happened
and this happened and there's no other
explanation and it continues doing
things I just feel like oh well I guess
that happens now it was yeah it was a
pre- internet world and we didn't know
what to do about it yeah yeah yeah I get
it because it's like that wasn't really
you couldn't call the cops they'd lock
you
up and when they didn't have any money
couldn't leave right they were young and
broke and I was just a kid yeah it was
[__] snowing outside yep I very much
like The Shining you were kind stuck
there for a little while we weren't
alone though there were other Bungalows
but I I and I don't know how many of
them were
full yeah so weren't alone per
se but we couldn't tell anybody we were
only there for a couple days yeah you
said we were there for like a week or
five five days four days five days
something like that and then uh went
back to Lois's house and it was
happening there yeah so it wasn't the
place that was totally you yeah yeah
like I said you'd never been there
before and as far as I know nobody ever
reported any weird activity of and it
got better at Lois's house so it it was
I had forgotten a lot of it red reminded
me of it CU I didn't want to remember it
but he remembered something the things
that it did through that knife and [__]
it was
weird
yeah okay so let's see where was I okay
so yeah the thing with the hat so the
glass is still there so these two cops
are still in the house now a couple more
cops did come so there were more cops in
the house also um neighbors started kind
of collecting around there being like
what the [__] is cuz they see all the
cops and they like what the [__] is
going on they said they had so many
neighbors like around the house and so
many liil L and stuff that they had to
like get cops out there to like Direct
traffic CU they were like clogging the
traffic up you know what I mean now the
cops that came because they were still
adhering to this like um all of this
destruction is caused by sound
vibrations Theory they decided they were
going to bring some uh some equipment to
measure and see if this was the case uh
you know they wanted to detect like some
high frequency vibrations or whatever
the [__] um so they did that but of
course they didn't find anything unusual
one thing that that was interesting was
that while all the equipment was running
there was absolutely no manifestations
at all but as soon as they turned the
[__] off then it started up again so uh
cop some cops were still in the house at
this
point um and then apparently these
little Fang like wounds started showing
up on renate who was the 32y old and
Lena who was the 61y old like on their
arms and stuff they f it bite um I guess
I'm not really sure but the cops
reported that they saw them like you
know just spontaneously appearing like
it's looked like snake bites or
something like that like little Fang now
the cop that got hit in the back did he
make a statement did he say anything
about it I don't know I guess that's all
he said but you know I mean that that's
what happened that was just in the
report cops saw it at the infield too
scared him yeah well like I said several
cops several cops saw this one yeah the
infield case the reporter saw it he said
he saw little Lego bricks bouncing
around and he said I had a very strange
feeling he well he got hit in the head
with a Lego yeah yeah yeah and he was
trying to be a British as [__] you know
what I mean during the interview he's
like you are just British as [__] you
see this and of course I I had a very
strange feeling so I know what you're
talking about you got so [__] scared
you nearly passed out you get vertigo
yeah that's his very strange feeling he
just didn't want to [__] show
weakness I
guess well no I mean the Brits love to
they're they're very like they like to
like downplay yeah very strange [__]
feel I got you bro like everything is
like understated yeah yeah yeah you know
what I mean very strange feeling [__]
[__] in your pants nearly [__] Los
that is a pretty strange
feeling I get so scared man during that
first few days that I'd [__] get
vertigo like I was going to pass
out well like I said that's not
surprising because you were a kid you'd
never seen anything like that before you
didn't know anything like that existed
and the I just feared something like
that existed and the phenomena that you
saw was extreme yeah uh by any measure
yeah so I mean it was very active yeah
and then it made blood them three drops
of Blood on the toilet paper that had me
[__] [__] where'd he get that blood
Lois has that yeah she she still got it
as far as I know we could do DNA test on
she sent me a picture of it when we were
doing the book we could do DNA test on
that and see whose blood that is that
would be I know you probably should do
that one of these days I don't think
it's cheap to do a DNA test but and
that's not a lot of blood it's three
like tiny little drops but maybe they
could do it but I don't I we probably
don't have enough money to do it
though but yeah so um so the two older
women they look like they're getting bit
by snakes or something like that like
just spontaneously on their arms later
on uh Renee had had a purse like her
purse and had $125 in it like in
cash and um the purse
disappeared so the cops did not think
this was paranor normal cuz they're like
well look we've had all these cops and
friends and stuff like that through here
so somebody must have taken it so they
locked down the house and like searched
everybody but could not find the purse
like nobody that was in there had taken
anything so this friend of hers like I
said her former employer whose name was
Emil NOA who I mentioned earlier he
actually stayed um him and his wife
stayed in the house with them like for
the next few days cuz he was curious
about what was going on um and he said
in his statement that pretty much
every piece of glass and crystal that
was in the house uh was broken after
that happened uh then all the dishes got
broken and then all of the like all of
the furniture started moving around like
couches and [__] like would move around
by themselves broke all the dishes
because it upset them and then the more
they worried about [__] the dishes
the more it broke the dishes yeah yeah
so like all the dishes got broken too so
man you was hopefully they had insurance
on that [__] because everything is
busted it's pissed off it I guess so
yeah um he also reported that he saw the
weird Fang wounds yeah uh appearing on
both R but no information they felt it
bite huh I yeah they didn't really say
anything about it it's just this she
just seems like it was mostly like other
people that witnessed it were they
breaking the scan or is it just an I
guess so because they said it looked
like they said it looked like a fanged
animal had bitten them like a snake or
something like so little like little
puncture wounds okay
they said there was blood they would
have reported that though maybe it's
just a bite like a cat bite if a cat
playing around biting you and it doesn't
go through the skin maybe maybe I don't
know but I mean that would still be
pretty weird like seeing that just
spontaneously I'd like to know if they
felt it or if they just saw it appear I
mean I'm sure they probably felt it I
would I would imagine did they feel a
mouth or did they just feel the [__]
spikes going in that's that's you know
weird man if they said they felt a mouth
I'm sure that that would have been
reported somewhere yeah
um so this guy this friend who was
staying with them he also said that he
was sitting at the kitchen table one
afternoon and they had this like hanging
lamp over the kitchen table like you
know like like he did back then and um
it just kind of fell
suddenly so he went up and it had just
been hanging like from its wire like on
a nail or whatever and he's like well
the nail was fine it wasn't pulled out
or nothing so he pulled the nail out and
put like a stronger one in there there
and then put the lamp back on um but he
said 20 minutes later it fell again and
broke on the
table um
also this uh this guy uh Emil uh whose
wife was also there like I said and all
three of the women who lived in the
house they're all in the living room
they hear all of this noise coming from
the kitchen and when they go in the
kitchen there were three steak knives
which had been in the you know the
cutlery drawer obviously
they were on the floor in a cross shape
which again was kind of similar to
something that you described making
shapes yeah uh so Emil is like what the
[__] that so he picks the knives up and
puts them back in the drawer everybody
goes back in the living room and then
they hear another noise a few minutes
later go back and the knives were right
back in the in the cross shape again on
the floor so uh so there was also
that um there was also uh there was a
clinical psychologist named David
Blumenthal who came who was called in to
investigate this and also the very
famous parapsychologist William R uh he
also came out to the house to
investigate um I read a bunch of his
books back in the 70s so uh yeah so he
got there so like I said there's a lot
of witnesses to this one now so William
R gets there he said for the first two
days he was in the house he didn't see
anything but on the third day he he was
in the kitchen alone but he could see
everybody else in the house like you
know they were all like within his field
of
vision so he hears a noise in the hall
he goes to check on it and there's like
a bath brush like one of the you know
like to scrub your back or whatever um
and it was just sitting like on one of
the stairs and it had just like
spontaneously appeared there and nobody
had put it there apparently yeah it's
typical yeah it's just yeah it's just
random [__] Ty sh it's random [__] this
is this is a real
phenomenon yeah in other words I'm
saying this is a real case just by what
they're talking about that matches up
perfectly yeah like I said there's no
Rhyme or Reason to it no deeper
message just kind of random displays of
things that it can do and it would tend
to kind of get a little bit more
sophisticated as it went like it was
learning it's weird very weird but it
shows you what's possible with
Consciousness somehow yeah it's pretty
weird
yeah um here's another thing that I
thought you might find interesting
because this is something that we've
talked about before like um on some
other cases that we've uh talked about
particularly like the Demon House case
the um the the one in uh Seattle you
know what I mean yeah not Seattle but
outside of Seattle with what was his
name Keith yeah
yeah uh so a couple days after that
William R has been staying in the house
and he's in the 's room and there was a
vase in there that had been in the
kitchen but it was in the it was in her
room now and it was made of glass
apparently was this was one of the very
few glass items that was still intact at
this point and it fell like right at his
between his feet like just kind of like
off the shelf with a really loud noise
but it didn't break yeah sounds familiar
doesn't it right that's what I'm saying
um and yeah we've talked about that
before like that's a pretty common I
know this like really weird but it's
pretty commonly reported in polter gu
stuff that stuff will hit the floor and
it either makes a lot more noise than
you think or a lot less noise it's never
the right amount it's never the right
amount of noise and you try to recreate
it throw the object again on the same
surface it doesn't sound anything like
that
yeah that's kind of like I said we had
that happen with the remote control cuz
it made like a much louder yeah bang
than it would have and it didn't bounce
um there was that too and then I think
in the um the Keith Linder case like it
was just this one of those little plast
you know those little round plastic
lights they're like battery powered and
you just like stick them on the wall you
know and you just push them and they
come on one of those fell off the wall
and it made like a like a really really
loud Ruckus even though it was just
plastic it should have just gone you
know what I mean and made like a nothing
noise so it's like uh Steve Mara when he
he was like we went up there and we kept
like pitching this thing at the floor
trying to make it make that noise again
and it just wouldn't he's like that he's
like now we recorded the sound that it
made and he's like the sound um what do
you call that the um spectr meteor yeah
yeah like the sound thing on sound the
sound thing um looked the same but it
was like much much louder like on the
first one but they couldn't get it to do
that again yeah like you know what I
mean so when the hit it sounded like a
thud it was like like a brick like a
brick yeah it sounded like a brick we
tried to rec re re uh [__] create it
we threw it again it just sounded like
click light plastic yeah cuz it's
plastic light light plastic yeah it just
went yeah like that it just made that
but it sounded like a break the first
time it just went and it didn't bounce
which it usually would bounce CU like I
said it doesn't weigh hardly anything so
yeah so I thought that was really
interesting that he reported and even
though it was glass it hit the floor and
it didn't
break now several days after renate's
purse had disappeared remember how I
said the purse that had $125 and it
disappeared um
she she was just standing there and
something brushed against her leg and
she looked down and there it
was um now what was it her purse okay
purse her purse yeah now there had
originally been $125 in the purse now
there was only $35 in the purse okay uh
but nothing else in the purse was
different you know what I mean so that
was the only thing but it just kind of
like showed up next to her leg one day
so and it had been gone for it's more
than a week I believe but it just
appeared wonder if they ever found the
money no I I don't think they ever did
yeah I don't know what happened to it
polter guys took it took it and hit it
he's a [__] thief that's what he is
can't spend it so just hit it cry inside
the wall yeah the polter guys going to
go down to 7-Eleven and buy some smokes
and like some [__] Reese's peanut
butter cups or something [__] your money
[Laughter]
yeah so I think like a day or two after
that
happened um apparently Lena the
61-year-old woman had collapsed on the
floor and needed help so the neighbors
called like an ambulance you know I mean
the police and stuff now they get there
and they find her laying on the floor
and she seemed like she was only partly
conscious you know what I mean now while
the cops were there though and this is
kind of interesting too I think you'll
also find this interesting while the
cops were there one of the cops not all
of them one of the cops said that he saw
the old woman pick up an ashtray and
throw it across the room and push over a
piano bench like while she was laying on
the ground all right one cop said he saw
that so since the cops told that cop
told the other cops about that they were
like oh well that's what's been causing
this old lady for whatever reason is
throwing [__] around so they arrested
her yeah disorderly conduct now renate
her daughter she was pissed off she's
like look um you know my mom has not
been doing this and you guys need to
take her to the hospital because she's a
diabetic and she might be going into
shock and you know she probably needs
medical attention or whatever so the
cops are like okay fine so they took her
to the hospital and they examined her
and then they released her and then they
took her to jail
now the next day she was brought before
a judge and the judge said tell you what
we'll dismiss the disorderly conduct
charges if you go back to Germany
because she was you know from Germany
obviously she's like so within 10 days
you have to go back to Germany otherwise
we're going to you're going to go to
trial or whatever so Lena said she would
and so they let her go
now so here's the thing I kind of feel
like the cops at this point we're like
oh well it was just this old lady to
doing this the whole time couldn't have
been however yeah like all the other
Witnesses cuz like I said it wasn't just
there was cops there there was a
psychologist there was a parir of
psychologist there was neighbors there
was like a couple of their friends and
stuff like that that had seen this stuff
and they're like look she couldn't have
done all of that um like and even like a
bunch of the other cops said there was
just there was like there was [__] going
on when she wasn't even in the room yeah
they said the same thing would happen
with like
um um Enfield Poltergeist I mean there
was obvious
psychokinetic stuff going on but then
Janet the focus would do something like
throw an object yeah but then said she
didn't throw it maybe she just didn't
remember throwing it the subconscious
part of her mind who's using this
psychokinesis is doing all this [__] and
then maybe there's a little bit of spill
over where she [__] throws it with a
physical object but it's it's another
Consciousness in other words kind of
like a multiple personality
type slightly disor slight
disorder which might be interpreted
interpreted as
possession you're being possessed by an
alternate ego
temporarily which that makes sense
because the possession case that [__]
[__] inspired The Exorcist was a pter
case yeah pter phenomenon appears to be
possession something sometimes it's not
though it's a psychic temper
tantrum and there's kind of like
multiple
facets of the personalities [__] a
you know working on each other in other
words the subconscious mind sometimes
taking over taking over conscious
control of the body or taking over
control of the body sometimes so who
knows maybe yeah we saw all those [__]
flying in that house who knows maybe
every now and then I did something and
didn't remember it I don't know yeah you
know it's it's it's
possible like you know I found the word
Go written on the wall on on the wall on
on the glass in wax that's we found
it how do you know I didn't do that and
didn't and and was and and don't
remember it right because it was an
alternate part of your Consciousness
doing it because that'd be an efficient
way of doing it because it'd be like you
do you do [__] sleepwalking true it's
like that you know you have an
unconscious part of your your
unconscious part of your mind [__]
moving your body around then you wake
the person up and they're like oh [__]
how did I get here right might have been
things like that happening maybe that's
maybe that's what she was doing when she
threw those objects she was kind of like
sleepwalking she must have been the
focus it's possible she must have been
the focus are you talking about this
case now this old lady yeah well but
we'll see if that was the thing because
like I said that one cop said Oh I
thought I saw her or some [__] which I
don't know if he did or not but um so
they're like oh so so they're like oh
well that explains all of it but like
pretty much all the other Witnesses were
like no it couldn't have because William
roll and Dr Blumenthal who had been
staying in the house for several days at
this point they're like look we tried to
preclude that possibility like we kept
her in sight the whole time like while
there was this one incident where um in
Lena's bedroom there was like this
knocking noise coming out that was like
this um this picture she had over her
bed that was like banging against the
wall like that and it's like we had her
hands in our hands like she was sitting
right there so she couldn't have been
doing it you know what she may have done
that but the cops wanted to wash their
hands in the case yeah they were
probably just like they were looking
somebody wanted to be a hero I saw the
case yeah that you know that's part of
but she may have thrown that stuff and
done that in an alternate State of
Consciousness like sleep and sometimes
and we've talked about this too and I
think we talked about it in particular
about the Enfield case and you see this
in poer guys cases too is that a lot of
times especially if it's an
adolescent um you know there'll be all
of this activity and then all these
people come to investigate the activity
and then nothing is really happening and
so then the focus adolescent gets caught
throwing something for example yeah like
happened in the nfield Poltergeist case
um but that doesn't necessarily mean
that all the other stuff before was them
throwing it I mean could mean that but
it doesn't necessarily mean that it
could just mean that well they feel bad
because nothing's happening so it's like
they're trying to like stir up
excitement or get the people to stay
another I think it is is called priming
the pump that
too you're you might be before an
audience that
is skeptical which might add a bunch of
pressure on the focus even
subconsciously pressure performance
anxiety so the kid fakes something to to
lighten the mood they oh yeah it did it
and then all of a sudden now it's easy
to do then then the phenomenon [__]
starts up yeah you got to psych yourself
up yeah so it might be that that could
be that because I could see that because
I did feel like when we were going to
show it to somebody in my case there was
like this performance anxiety like oh
it's GNA make you look like a fool it's
not going to do anything and it would
hold back right then it would do
something small and see there it is then
it do something big it perform you had
like like Prime like grease in the
wheels it's almost kind of like the
Poltergeist has performance anxiety it's
like performance
anxiety exactly it's like it's like
PE pa pa yeah yeah Ben said the charge
was throwing [__] around throwing [__]
around yeah said seems pretty harsh she
would only get a fine wouldn't she yeah
that's what I would think maybe they
were just kind of threatening her
because she's like ah she's not like
wanted her to leave they yeah she's an
immigrant we don't want her here I don't
know uh Danny Rowling said what state
does this take place in this was uh
Indiana indianap Indianapolis Indian
indana this was
1962 now uh kind of fueling the theory
that Lena the 61-year-old woman was the
focus of this was that uh she did indeed
go back to
Germany uh you know as as she was was uh
supposed to and when she went back to
Germany on March 31st of 1962 I believe
um the phenomena completely
stopped so it would seem uh that she was
probably the one causing it there have
been some theories that maybe it was
renate the
32-year-old um because her and her uh
the relationship she had with her mother
was very uh ridden with conflict I guess
it was very
contentious um so it could be that she
was causing it but it does seem
in light of the fact that as soon as she
left the house or left the country um it
stopped I believe there were like a
couple of other isolated incidents like
here and there but nothing like this
whole like glass breaking furniture
moving shenanigans that happen like all
of that stuff like completely stopped as
soon as uh Lena gcki went back to
Germany and moved out of the house so it
would seem that this 61-year-old woman
was probably the focus of this
Poltergeist again very very unusual but
it could be like according to um
everything that I've read and like the
stuff that we've talked about and
everything like that anytime that
there's this kind of really contentious
family relationship I don't think
necessarily it has to do with the
person's age even though obviously you
know
when kids are going through puberty or
stuff like that it's this really
tumultuous time and then if you have
family drama on top of it then that's
going to fuel the fire even more but I
mean it could happen with an older
person like you weren't here but as soon
as that woman moved back to Germany all
the [__] stopped yeah which would seem
to indicate that she was probably the
one yeah I don't think it has to be a
young kid yeah not it's just yeah it
just usually is but I don't think that's
always the right I don't think that's
always the case um and and apparently I
could do it every now and then not as
good as it was yeah although if I
believed I could get was as good as it
was it could probably come
back yeah I I just don't want it yeah
because you don't really know I don't
know what it's going to do yeah I mean I
I know you I've known you for a long
time and your subconscious is a very
scary place yeah so it's like Yeah and I
don't know if you have complete control
over it I don't think so so it's like I
I might have to a dark side of the force
that's what I mean so it's like I might
have to like start wearing armor or
something like that cuz you would like
start pitching and [__] at me have
anything to do with you no probably not
like you don't really seem to get like
all that
[__] wouldn't have anything to do
with you it would do it would do stuff
for itself
right which is still like that's scary
enough in itself yeah CU I don't know
what it wants well and that's what I
mean and I think even and I think even
the most insightful person yeah doesn't
know what kind of like [__] uh
nefarious like thoughts you have down
there sometimes
like now and then I'll have kind of like
what the fu where did that come from you
know what I mean so and I think
everybody has that and also you don't
know how you're going to react in a
certain situation too like that you've
never experience so I kind of feel like
a lot
of a a lot of your own uh subconscious a
lot of your own Consciousness is really
not known to you yeah too which is kind
of frightening to think about so so if
you had something something that was
reacting to that that wasn't in your
control then there's all kind of like
scary [__] that could happen yeah
looking back on it it's like it was
trying not to cross certain um Rivers
you know mean certain boundaries it
didn't seem to cross never touched
anybody in Anger it never really
threatened anybody well that's good it
never seemed to want to go out of its
way to scare you away it wanted you to
watch what it could do more than
anything else you'd get scared cuz you
don't know what the [__] this thing is
and what it's doing but it would make
happy faces and [__] and I I guess it's
was just trying to say it's all good but
you can interpret that happy face as
something sinister too it's just
something creepy CU it appeared out of
nowhere like is it laughing at us you
know what is it doing you know yeah that
could be interpreted lots of different
ways it's not necessarily happy because
it's going to kill us with a problem
so you
know I by then we knew it was going to
hurt us yeah but still it was just
creepy but see you don't know you never
know I mean they don't usually it's an
outside force and you're not in control
of it right so you don't know what it
seemed to try to make friends kind of
but then it would go off and do some
other [__] that would [__] spooky you
know yeah it just wasn't real consistent
I mean the most violent thing that it
did while we were you know while while I
was experiencing it was tearing that
[__] off the off the off the counter off
the um the cabinet and breaking all that
stuff I wasn't home at that time you but
you were like really mad about something
he wasn't mad at me he was just mad
about something else no it [__]
sounded like [__] uh a huge crash was
instant all of it at once it wasn't like
a process of this falling and that one
falling this it was all of it at once
bam three of them horses and pulled that
[__] pulled that molding down in in Ho
it did it was it was that piece of
molding was probably about 5T long yeah
about that and it would snap easily and
it was nailed in but the nails had
pulled out and it was on the ground
intact like somebody had wrenched it off
like the whole thing yeah without
breaking it right yeah it came off just
nail it back up yeah came off in one pie
and then the nails were still sticking
out like like that and I couldn't I
couldn't do that by hand yank that thing
off of there without breaking it it it's
flimsy it's just that little wooden like
not even wood it's like that fake and it
came crashing down with everything else
just in one stroke
pow yeah how the [__] did that happen
and the and the the nails weren't even
straight they were all [__] bent yeah
they were all bent and sticking out yeah
wrenched that it looked like somebody
wrenched it forcefully uniformly without
[__] a uniform amount of [__]
pressure on it without snapping it it
just was pulled it off and and it didn't
pull it off and throw it down it was
just boom yeah it all just came down
boom and it and it came out out yeah
like it didn't come down straight down
straight down it would gone onto the
onto the stove top it was five or six
feet out from where it was on the
counter yeah like near the like on the
an AR in an arc but faster than a fall
bam yeah all of it see but that whatever
had it had a hold of it the whole time
right the point I'm making is that if it
can do that then and you were not in
control of that you were just mad and it
did that when you turned your back then
it could
do lots of different things and like I
said that's kind of the same case here
it's like this was basically like
[__] pitching big heavy Crystal bowls
around and [__] like that that could
easily just like Wing that at your head
and kill you yeah you know it doesn't
usually you know I don't think I've I
don't think I've really heard of a case
where anyone was
killed by you know rocks falling from
the ceiling or you know somebody
pitching up but that doesn't mean that
it couldn't happen you know what I'm
saying anytime it threw anything it made
[__] was like shot like that pin it
shot it at me like a [__] bullet and
it hit me it sounded like it was [__]
hard
clack but it's I didn't feel it very
much and it and it went back into the
room and bounced off my wrist like
that like a bullet yeah but it was loud
but I it was like it pulled the punch it
didn't hurt it was
weird yeah maybe it just kind of wanted
to be like [__] with you but yeah
whenever it had it it had it the whole
time I could see it there's a streak you
know underneath my field of vision it
would and went back into the room as I
was shutting the door red was standing
right behind he jumped we both jumped
out of our skin did you see that and he
goes yeah yeah I says that didn't happen
and he goes yeah did he say no no no no
no no no no that didn't happen went went
into
denial
yeah but yeah I mean this case in
particular it does seem like William R
the other psychologists that were there
stuff like that really do seem to think
that Lena the 61-year-old woman was the
focus because like most of the [__]
happened when she was present or seemed
to be focused around her somehow and the
fact that it all stopped when she left
like abruptly um would seem to suggest
that she was probably the one at the
center of it so again very unusual for a
61-year-old woman to be the focus of
poltergeist activity but apparently the
case here so uh I think it's time for
another drink actually yeah demig God
says great show he has to leave you you
can watch it recorded yeah we're we'll
we'll be here for another little while
cuz that was only the first case but
that I think that was the longest one
though yeah so this case this is this
one has always fascinated me um because
this is not only kind of an unusual case
of like an old he wasn't that much older
I think he was 19 or 20 like uh who they
are pretty sure the focus was but this
was interesting because it took place at
a workplace and not like in a house
which you don't usually usually I know
there's there's that one kind of famous
what was it um rosenheim or I can't
remember what one it was but that one
with that girl that came to work at that
office and like all the lights would
swing behind her and [__] like that um
so that so that was a workplace one but
this was a workplace one that I think
you don't hear as much about and I think
it's kind of interesting because it
happened in Miami uh right here in Miami
Florida well we're not in Miami Florida
but we're in Florida anyway so this one
happened in
1966 and I don't even know if this one
has a name so the Miami Poltergeist um
the name of the company where it
happened was called tropication Arts so
I don't know if it's called that
somewhere but I usually just see it
called P the Miami
Poltergeist so um this didn't last very
long as a lot of poltergeist outbreaks
don't but it was very destructive and
very very active and a lot again there
were a lot of witnesses uh to this
one and this was another case where [__]
just like started happening
spontaneously like people had been
working at this warehouse for like a
really long time and nothing had
happened but then all of a sudden B bam
like 1966 all of this kind of [__]
started happening so like I said this
company was called tropication Arts
Incorporated uh this was a wholesale
company um based out of Miami and their
whole thing was that you know all if
when you come to Florida and you go to
like International Drive or something
and there's like all those cheesy
tourist shops where they have like all
those like ugly mugs and you know
alligator [__] and stuff well not
alligator [__] but you know what I mean
like [__] with alligators on it um stuff
like that that was what this company
made they made like mugs and beer steins
and stuff like that had like Florida
[__] on it you know what I mean like
tourist [__] yeah I think this I think
gift shop I think that's actually made
Mexico out stuff is
it well this wasn't this was made this
was this was in Miami okay they made it
right there so they made it right there
okay uh but yeah they it they painted
them there and all right so so it was
like this big Warehouse I don't know if
it's still there or not probably
not so um so what happened this was like
the end of 1966 in
December now the first thing that
happened was that you know people come
into work and they find these they had
these uh like beer steins they were made
out of this amber glass yeah I remember
those and um the bunch of them were
broken on the
floor now they didn't think anything
about this they're just kind of like oh
well maybe a box fell off a shelf or
something like that like I said that's
what you would think but then it started
to seem like every day like the
employees would show up to this
warehouse and there was always Glass
Broken like you know there'd be Glass
Broken in the aisles or like a box boxes
would have fallen off and there was like
just [__] all over the
floor and they started to notice too
that every time that something fell off
a shelf or something was broken it was
always in an eye where nobody was you
know what I mean and it was usually from
somewhere either where nobody was or
that was from like too high up for
anybody to reach you know what I mean
like you'd need a ladder to get up there
so it wasn't like somebody was just
going we and like going like knocking
[__] off you know what I mean so it was
that kind of thing and it's happening
while they're in there working sometimes
but then sometimes they would come in in
the morning and there would just be [__]
broken so they'd be working they hear
the glass break or they just find yeah
some yeah sometimes right so um so you
got your warehouse manager his name was
um Alvin labim and the owner of the
place his name was Glenn Lewis now
obviously they didn't think anything
paranormal was going on they just
thought like some of their workers were
idiots or were just dropping [__] or
were breaking [__] on purpose um you
know just to be [__] uh and all the
workers said no man like we don't we
didn't touch it seriously but you know
they're losing a lot of money they're
losing a lot of stock cuz all of this
stuff is broken right so as the next
month goes on um um the activity start
seems to increase
right um and at one point the manager
and the owner decide well this can't be
the employees doing this because there
was just [__] broken everywhere and
there was stuff that was like it would
happen when no one was in there and like
stuff would happen like over there when
everyone was over here you know what I
mean so it was that kind of [__] so
they're like well there has to be
something else going on um and sometimes
some of the employees would even see
stuff falling off the shelf like like
things would fall off the shelf like one
thing two thing three thing like that
and like nobody was there wow you know
what I mean so they would see that kind
of [__] um just Bam Bam Bam and I
believe from a distance H I believe at
least a dozen Witnesses reported seeing
[__] just falling off like in sequence
like off of the Shelf is it coming out
in an arc did they give any any details
well we'll get into that like in a
second um so obviously the people that
work in this Warehouse are starting to
flip out cuz they're like oh my God this
[__] is [__] haunting what the hell
is going on like for real like they
thought it was like something bad was
going on so the manager calls the cops
um and he actually told the cops as far
as I know that he thought it was a ghost
um and he's like look there's I know
this sounds weird but there's a ghost in
here he's breaking all my [__] so please
come here and see what you can do about
it so they had a cop come out his name
was William uh killiam and he comes out
and he's just like oh my God I can't
believe I get this [__] detail but he
comes out and he saw some of the [__] as
well like he saw some of the [__] just
falling us he's like oh that is [__]
weird so he calls a couple of other
officers like about you guys got to come
see this [__] so a bunch of other
officers
come and they also had the thing where
they'd all be standing over here
nobody's over here in this part of the
warehouse and they hear a bunch of [__]
like just falling off the shelves and
then they go over there and it's like
all this shit's broken so it seemed like
you know much like were saying earlier
like [__] doesn't happen when you're
looking directly at it it would always
kind of be a thing where you know you'd
be in this aisle and in the next aisle
over you would hear all this [__]
smashing and then you'd go over there
and look and then like something in this
aisle you were just in with smash like
it would do that kind of thing yeah cuz
it can't it's not trying to be clever
right I'm I'm convinced that it can't
alter the location of that object or add
any kind of energy to it while you are
consciously looking at it because you
are confirming its [__] location
location and space and time and what its
status is when you're not looking at it
it's potentially in a place and whatever
does this is in that same place where
potential
is so it can only act on it when you're
not looking at it because that's where
it is that's that's where that force is
it's the only way I can describe it
that's what I feel it it was I mean that
does make sense yeah it's on the same
wavelength with but yeah when you're not
looking when nobody's looking they said
that was pretty common that like [__]
would break in this and everybody would
run over to see what it was and then
[__] would break in the aisle that you
were just in they said that would happen
all the time now interestingly there
were two witnesses uh two employees at
this place and they said that they
actually did see a couple of items
before it fell they said that the thing
on the Shelf would vibrate and bounce a
little bit up and down and then it would
lift up and fall out like that yeah they
said they they said they saw they saw I
wonder if they actually saw the whole
process or were eyes dancing around were
they blinking I don't know but that's
what two people reported seeing that
they was kind of like vibrate like that
I saw that plastic shot glass fall
through all those shelves and hit the
bottom and
go for a second and I was looking at it
while I was
going maybe there's just certain kind of
motion it can do while you're looking at
it but then there's other things it
can't do yeah or maybe it's just harder
when you're looking at it I don't know
but it seems to prefer it when you're
not looking looking at it yeah cuz like
I said it seems like most of the time
you see St when it's already in motion
which happens here like it would happen
like the next aisle over then you got to
ask yourself you're confirming where it
is when you're looking at it but you
can't see the backside of it of that
object maybe the back side of that
object its location is not confirmed
because you can't see that side of it
right it's it can though so it moves the
back side of the object the front side
is just connected to it
maybe it's something like that yeah I
don't [__] know I don't know either I
don't know how quantum physics works if
anybody tells you then how quantum
physics Works they're lying well even
physicists will tell you they will tell
you that they don't know how it works so
like we're not really sure yet yeah and
we're experts in this [__] yeah they're
still trying to figure it out the
universe is not it's weird it's not it's
counterintuitive threedimensional space
is not what it appears to be that's
really what he goes down SpaceTime is
not what it appears to be time may not
be all that real that's the thing so
there's a lot of problems we're just
perceiving a world through census and
that's not the way the world really is I
mean we just have like a little meat
computer I'm here we're not really
equipped to really understand what real
to deal with like we only we can only
understand like just what we needed to
do yeah which isn't all that complicated
the father of physics that got 99% of it
figured out was [__] Isaac Newton we
mostly live in the Newtonian World there
real simple [__] okay gravity and
[__] how things bounce and how things
move when you start talking about
einsteinian stuff and [__] quantum
physics and [__] dilation of
SpaceTime really advanced concepts we
don't really live in that world we're
not traveling close to the speed of
light all that's imaginational exercises
that turn out to be re real yeah we know
it because of satellites you got to
adjust their clocks a moving satellite
its clock is not running the same as
yours clocks there is no un clock to say
what time it is for everywhere
everybody's got their own clock
depending on how fast they're moving
relativity [__] right now here's
another thing you're in a piece of space
and your clock is running
one at the rate you think is normal but
on the other side of the universe and
the universe is
expanding a place at the edge of the
visible universe is now accelerating
away from you at at near the speed of
light so that's clock is not running the
same as your clock nope all right even
though that guy's clock he seems to be
normal and your clock isn't isn't
running right because more space is
being added it's bubbling up and things
are being pushed apart they're not
traveling through space just more space
is being added yeah in between all this
this which like I said is weird it's C
you're just being Dr along it it's like
being on the surface of balloons blowing
up because that's not our day-to-day
experience it's not your day experience
like I said our day-to-day experience is
to a large degree dictated by our little
meat computers which are awesome and
complex but not complex enough to really
that guy that guy at the edge of the
universe that's that's moving away from
you near the speed of light if you were
to see him through a telescope it's not
possible but if you were to see him as a
telescope he's moving real slow like his
[__] is moving and then he would just
fade away yeah like where'd that [__]
go you should you should teach physics
classes people would learn it good he
vanished away where'd that [__] go
where' that [__] go he probably be
Frozen and you'd probably see him for
billions of years not moving yeah and
then it would probably just fade away
eventually as the photons sto arriving
right you know but yeah that's what
would happen yeah the photons would stop
arriving and he'd be long gone and that
that dude Slipped
Away into another [__] version of
SpaceTime because the space that he's
occupying is moving away from you faster
than the speed of
light yeah even though he's not moving
the speed of light
that just more distance is being added
in between those two points it's
bubbling up expansion of the universe
well [__] time on your end and his
end is totally different yeah they're
not you're like in a new universe or
compared to each
other not we're in the same we just
don't we are not accurately perceiving
space and time and energy and matter
like I said we didn't needed to right it
wasn't really gerine to our day-to-day
to do with running down deer and killing
an making Furs making clothes that's
what we come from right and I mean to be
honest I kind of I I'm kind of like an
optimist in that way because I'm like
look our human brains were built for
that but look at all the [__] we figured
out I'm like that's pretty good yeah and
then you look you look at a wasp from
the point of view of a wasp it its
universe is totally different because
it's just seen it through senses that
are nothing like ours
mhm yeah that always kind of freaks me
out too like they never like birds and
insects and stuff like that they see
different um you know Visual spectrums
and their experience their senses are
different their their sense of hearing I
don't think I don't think they have it
[__] vibration all yeah it's like
vibrational hearing and they like I said
their vision is completely different
they're seeing ultraviolet yeah they see
in a different um
spectrum and the way they fly around
like the speeds they fly around and
stuff like that probably uh it Alters
their perceptions and they're like them
[__] Xenomorphs man they think it's
totally normal to impregnate a [__]
paralyzed creature and you're young just
live in it and eat it then comes out
fully formed comes out fully formed yeah
whereas humans be horrified yeah and it
comes out knowing everything it needs to
know hey what's up I've just been born
let's go to
work that that kind of universe does man
I wish human babies were like that you
all ready to go to work yeah the baby
would just pop out and it could already
feed itself and like get job and
everything job that'd be [__] awesome
yeah [__] humans we're pathetic now I
mean well I mean that's the whole reason
like our brains are so complicated that
it takes a long time for us to get up to
speed and they're all pretty much
exactly the same they're like clones of
each
other it's not babies like humans not
not human babies insects and stuff
they're all clones yeah
yeah although I kind of I suspect that
they might be well like bees and [__]
like I think are smarter than we give
them credit for yeah I'm just going to
say that right now um I actually I think
all animals are probably smarter than we
yeah no kidding run out of time we're
not running out of time it's only 9 o'
it's we're fine like I said the first
case was the longest like we can just
you know what I mean okay so all of this
stuff is happening at this Warehouse so
this Paranormal Investigator named Susie
Smith she's the first one to show up um
and she stayed she would come there like
every day like every weekday and like
stay there all day and log all of the
weird [__] that was happening so she
logged like hundreds and hundreds of uh
incidents and then good old William roll
again he showed up for this one too uh
he also brought uh Jay Gaither Pratt uh
with him also a
parasca they said most of the stuff that
gets thrown or broken or whatever is in
this one particular area of the
warehouse all that was there it was like
a couple of desks like um some shelves
there was like three shelves like that
and then one like along the back wall um
they also said that almost all of the
objects that were thrown or broken were
either those glass beerstein like the
amber glass or they had like these
highball glasses that had a zombie on
them um so those were like other [__]
was thrown around too but that was like
the overwhelming majority were those two
things for whatever reason now the other
thing that they
noticed getting back to the actual topic
of the show was that whenever [__]
happened
it was always when this one worker was
there now this was a 19-year-old young
man named Julio Vasquez I remember this
case he was uh yeah he was Cuban yep and
he was a shipping clerk and pretty much
everything that happened was when he was
in the area like [__] did never happen
when he was off work like it was always
when he was there and always when he was
close by um and whenever he was in a bad
mood the stuff would be like a lot more
intense like it would happen a lot more
uh and like I said when he wasn't at
work like nothing would happen now
William R and uh Dr Pratt were there for
10 days I believe and they uh concluded
that Julio was probably the focus uh and
that he was causing the [__] uh through
rspk obviously now uh one thing that was
kind of interesting it be funny if they
docked his pay okay you ow break you're
breaking all this
[__] yeah
right I mean yeah um now one thing that
was kind of interesting about this
particular case too was that
sometimes uh the Poltergeist The Entity
whatever you want to call it would
actually do stuff that the
parapsychologist like asked it to do you
know what I mean yeah ours that ours
responded to
yeah yeah yeah like this this also did
that yeah like so what William R would
do was he would take some of the like
highly breakable stuff like I'm sure the
manager was like pissing his pants in
this like oh my God you're breaking all
our stuff but it's just like you know
the polter guys was already breaking it
so what are you going to do and he's
like so he would take the stuff and then
he would move it to like one part on the
Shelf where you know a bunch of stuff
had broken before and then he's just
kind of like hey break that stuff or
move that stuff or whatever and almost
always it would do it yeah so it ours
yeah so it it was pretty much so so he's
like yeah it was very responsive like to
requests um now one thing he wanted to
see if Julio was doing this um if he was
just the focus or if he was like doing
it like consciously consciously or
physically right so he's like so he
takes one of the zombie glasses he puts
it on a shelf behind like several feet
behind where Julio was working and then
he just like kept an eye on him like
from behind the [__] shelf or
whatever so Julio at the time he's he
was working so he had a clipboard in one
hand and then he had like some kind of
alligator thing like in the other like a
toy or a mug or something in the other
hand so he wasn't looking back there he
didn't know what was going on nothing
like that he was kind of crouched down
um and you know there was stuff in both
of his hands and still the glass behind
him just went and crashed on the floor
and William roll said I was looking at
him the entire time he did not turn
around he did not touch that glass he
didn't do anything it was like four or
five feet behind him um you know and he
didn't do anything that would suggest
that he was like faking
it um so yeah nobody had been there it
just did it by itself now another thing
that William R decided to do he took
this whole box full of the beer mugs
again the manager is just like oh my God
no but yeah so he takes a whole box of
beer mugs and he puts it um he he goes
to like one of the most active areas and
he puts it on this shipping desk like
puts it on top of desk like almost
almost kind of like baiting the [__]
Poltergeist and they're like yeah break
all this [__] uh and you know just
obviously uh the Poltergeist took the
Box the whole box picked it up off the
table and went onto the floor all the
mugs didn't break but three of them did
um hulio was in the area but he was 5 or
6 feet away from the desk and had his
back toward it so obviously he hadn't
done anything but he was there um the
only other person that was in the
warehouse at the time that that happened
was way on the other side of the room so
obviously it did it by itself the
phenomena the phenomena is fast yeah it
also has dexterity it can stack objects
it can make shapes that Mak
sense it evidently can either teleport
matter or make it penetrate matter like
you know things come from somewhere I
guess it came through the wall I don't
know or like I said that that one glass
came out of that hat through that hat
and hit that cop in the
back yeah which means that
it matter doesn't mean much to
it matter is mostly empty space anyway
true so
uh either it moves it into a higher
Dimension or it just grabs hold of it
somehow just moves it right through
another object none the atoms even hit
but this is what I want to know it can
break these glasses
can it put one back
together it never seems to do that
though no I guess because it's much
easier to like destroy something and
then to create something but what I
wonder what would happen if you
challenge it I want you to put that
broken mug back together I wonder if
just like it was I wonder if it would
try or would it try to fool you and just
take it away and put a new one there put
a new one there that would probably be
easier yeah just like buying somebody a
new thing
if it would probably take the old the
old one away The Broken Pieces away away
and put a new in there and and and try
to fool you that's what I PRI cuz all
the energy that it would take I mean it
takes much less energy to just like
break something then put it back
together the way it was yeah but it had
a dexterity right it might be able to
fuse things back together I don't know
it can make it can make p penetrate
through other matter can it rejoin two
pieces that have been
broken i' I'd start with something easy
like a glass rod see if you it could get
it to fix yeah there was just like two
pieces just two pieces to put together
yeah see if it would try cuz it
would it would it would fulfill requests
if it could do it it the only thing it
threw a tantrum was we asked it to write
it did not want to do it just threw the
pen just threw the pen at him yeah it
didn't want to give [__] you I'm not
writing it didn't want to give any
information CU you want you asked what
its name was right yeah all kind how old
it was stuff like that it didn't it
didn't want to give any information it
just wanted to demonstrate what it could
do right and keep you occupied keep you
watching
it yeah so remember how I said the
witnesses earlier said that they had
seen like some of the stuff on the
shelves and they thought it would like
vibrate and like lift up a little bit
Yeah so the parapsychologist wanted to
check and see if this was the case um
and also they wanted to make sure that
[__] wasn't just like sliding off the
shelf you're just like falling off so
they're like what they did was they took
some of the glasses you know that were
you know very commonly broken and they
would push them back and then they would
put notebooks in front like that that
were only like that
high and then it so and then they sat
and watched them now
interestingly some of the objects that
they had pushed way back and put
notebooks in front of still ended up
broken so obviously they were lifting up
a little bit because the notebooks were
still there yeah but the ship behind
them had come out and broken so
obviously they were lifting up at least
two inches good before they came out and
broke on the floor right yeah so uh so
yeah now the these two parapsychologists
they said they logged about um 13
incidents where they had put a Target
item in a spot and watched it until it
jumped off the shelf on its own 13
incidents of that they they were
actively looking at it they were
actively looking at it when it did it
all right uh and they were also watching
everybody that was at work um and you
know obviously nobody was near the [__]
now when they did try and this is very
common too and this is again why like a
lot of Skeptics say is like why didn't
you take a picture of it they did say
that they try to take picture and video
and stuff like that but when they would
turn the cameras on nothing would happen
yeah that sounds typical right so um you
could never catch it in the ACT yeah it
was too fast
and unpredictable and yeah I mean the
cameras back then right yeah this was
1967 big ass expensive cameras and it
was expensive to record
anything cell phone of today' be a lot
handier and I could have never caught
anything that's happened recently with a
cell phone it's just because you're not
ready you're not ready for it you not
even thinking about it you're not
expecting it just does [__] when you're
not thinking about it for the same
reason why girls don't catch serial
killers that kill them on their cell
phones they weren't expected it you know
yeah that's what I mean it's like who
the [__] thinks it's like oh I should
take a picture of this [__]
right well they're even Poltergeist is
even faster than that and more
unpredictable than that you'll never
catch it even if you know that it's
going on we had a Polaroid camera at
Mammoth we could only capture the
aftermath we could never catch anything
in motion yeah so it's like when you see
the photos you're like why did they take
a picture of that yeah but they were
taking a picture of it because that was
all we could catch what it did of what
it did they're in the book the pictures
are in the book now not po guys yeah but
it's just yeah and Polaroid camera like
you used to be what it used to be like
10 yeah it were almost like a dollar a
photo yeah they were yeah it wasn't
cheap yeah you know we it was 10 or 12
like in one packet that you stuck in and
I think we only had one packet of them
things yeah and they just took pictures
of like oh look it's a rocking chair
rocking chair upside down a bed with
like towels on it yeah you know what I
mean mean they took pictures of that
because that and that's why you know
what I mean if you just saw them out of
context you'd be like why the [__] would
you take a picture of that stuff but
yeah was things that it did yeah but
that's the thing but yeah so apparently
this whole entire time that um the
parascience that they personally
witnessed of just random objects moving
right that they couldn't uh explain
um now they couldn't find any evidence
that anyone was doing it um they
couldn't find any natural explanation
earthquake or anything like that so they
figured that like I said probably rspk
or you know Poltergeist it was hul
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis yes
it recurs over and over again it's
spontaneous you can't plan for it it's
psychokinesis somehow the Mind moved it
don't know how it's a subconscious mind
I wasn't consciously able to do
it I could consciously astral project
though but it was better if I didn't
expect that too that was a lot later
yeah yeah uh William R also noticed
something very interesting which maybe
you want to weigh in on he said that um
Julio Vasquez who was the focus they
thought um the items that fell from the
shelves or flew from the shelves but
were the farthest away from where he was
at the time
traveled the
farthest but objects that were close to
him when they fell didn't move that far
so he thought um well this was his
theory anyway that that um Julio had
what he called a sigh field PSI field
yeah um and he's like maybe this field
like kind of goes in a circular motion
around the person and so like if it's
close by like it just kind of goes like
that but if it's far away it's like goes
farther I don't know like I I don't know
like all the logistics of it steuart
Hammer off but that's kind of what he
was thinking steuart Hammer off his
explanation would be called uh Quantum
Soul Theory and it's that your brain is
a bunch of neurons but wrapped around it
entangle with each other are a bunch of
quantum particles that are in
superposition and in quantum
entanglement with each
other and that is kind of like a soul
it's conscious it gives you that feeling
of being it gives you a point of view if
you take
anesthesia it deadens all the
microtubules inside the brain that cause
that and after that you will be
unconscious even though you're awake and
and talking like I was talking to Jenny
when she came out of [__] anesthesia
she was I was talking to her for a half
hour she didn't remember any of it she
was unconscious because her Quantum
field had been shut
down or somehow maybe not shut down but
disconnected
from the brain so you so it's slightly
like an out of- Body Experience then
when the anesthesia wears off she goes
back I've been through it myself it's an
anesthesia through S surgeries I don't
remember it either okay what did I say
just talk about normal stuff just normal
stuff talk about talking about surgery
and was she was getting implants she was
like oh talking about her boobs oh
they're big you know see I don't
remember that all yeah yeah they look
good like I said the first thing I
remember I remember waking up in the
room for a second yeah but then the next
thing I remember was you helping me to
the car and then the next thing I
remember was me being at back at your
house in bed and you bringing me a
sandwich yeah that's the next thing I
remember yeah you didn't remember but
you talk the whole time that's hilarious
and you're yeah so um the Sigh field
that he's talking about there's a more
Mo there's a more modern description of
it quantum Soul Theory
or you know uh it's a it's a cloud of
in cloud of Nano particles they're
[__] little subatomic damn particles
Quantum particles and they're slightly
outside of SpaceTime too okay and
they're
all entangled with quantum entanglement
with each other so theoretically if the
body and the brain dies that field will
still be entangled so you'll still have
a point of view which that checks out
without a body experiences that I've had
you don't remember a whole lot about
yourself or the memories that you had
you can access them if you want to but
you're mostly a point of view you can
see or
experience but you're not really who you
were you're more childlike I guess you
could say but you can access any
information anywhere at any time just by
wanting it and then you can get that
information but then as soon as you
don't need the information anymore it's
gone it's not it's like it's not
recorded because there's no brain to
record it right
you're about the size of a pingpong ball
and you can see in every direction at
once in any in in
any Spectrum you want to see
in uh you can hear or not hear or you
can change everything and see Quantum
particles or subatomic particles or you
can actually just say [__] it and wink
out and go
into kind of like what some people call
astral worlds which are like other
dimensions of vibration there way I can
describe it
then there's a thing like a ploma which
is a place it's just a big white ball of
singing and you you see that thing and
you know that if you go in there you
never come out or at least not as you
are it's a sea of Consciousness it's the
place where all Consciousness goes it's
where all the creatures that can that
can experience come from that it's like
an ocean of Consciousness like a Quantum
or like a like a un Universal
Consciousness if you go in there you're
recycled as soon as I saw it I was like
I knew what that was it's like going
home you want to go but then you know
but if I go in there I won't I can't
come back out right not as not as I am
or who it'll be it'll be a because
you're basically dissolving into an
ocean so your version of your version of
identity is kind of erased and it's
traded with other people's
identities but they're little primitive
identities they're just point of
views your point of view merges with
everybody else's yeah the Greeks called
it the Poma the place where the gods
come
from yeah I get it
m yeah so it's all part of that same
version of
reality Poltergeist is related to all
this yeah Quantum Consciousness and the
afterlife Jenny did not believe in the
afterlife but I've seen it it's it's not
an afterlife in the way of like you
survived death it's where you came from
yeah I mean like I'm open to it but yeah
I just you know I've never seen anything
like you've seen so yeah your
personality and who you are now is just
a role that you chose to to to take
because when you selected this life you
already knew the destiny you knew the
story it's like you paid admission to
see that movie man like that because you
I chose to be a broke ass go chick yeah
[__] why did I choose that well yeah
well you choose you choose to live so
you can experience okay because you
can't experience in the ploma or in the
spiritual worlds really it's kind of
stagnant you get bored after a while
because it's it's like being in the
Internet it's too uh uh what's a good
way to put
it it's too um interactive you're going
to get exactly what you want you'll go
everywhere you want so the limitate it's
not fun cuz there's no limitations right
I got you you know what I'm talking
about although I think in my next life I
would like to choose to be a billionaire
and it's outside of SpaceTime so there's
no progress It's a
singularity you know what I'm talking
about right it's outside of space and
time it's a singularity so when you're
over there your purpose isn't isn't
being fulfilled it's it's stagnant I
guess a good way so you choose to do
things okay but they're kind of fun even
the uffing is supposed to be fun and
then you go back and then you can erase
yourself seemingly I guess seemed like
it maybe I chose this because I knew I'd
meet you Tom could be probably not
probably not and I knew that you would
entertain me for years it's it's it's
it's done it's done for uh it's not as
important reason as you really think I'm
just it's because there isn't much else
to do yeah well you know what I mean you
you can be birds or animals or insects
or aliens or whatever I'd like to be a
kitty you can be anything you want you
can be alien that would be cool too
alien souls or you can just live over
there and not be reincarnated I guess
but every time you do this kind of like
your past personalities were just a role
that you played they're kind of erased
you don't remember them you don't need
to it's like you don't remember all the
video games you
played yeah that's
true Karen Lee says cool show tonight oh
thank you thank you yeah did a whole
show on that was called out of body
experiences on this channel you it was
long time I tell all the [__]
near-death experiences that I had out of
body experiences yeah he had some weird
[__] happen and it's
all related to
Poltergeist it's the same phenomenon
it's just a different aspect of it DVD
Dragon says I would be a Subway sandwich
yeah well one of the new ones with like
where they have like the actual meat s
right now everything everything that
exists in the material world has a
Consciousness but it only has the
consciousness of what it is like a rock
has the consciousness of a
rock is the rock a rock just a rock so
and which isn't much okay so everything
is kind of conscious in a certain way
just there's not conscious in the way
that a human is or some kind of other
worldly being maybe would I would call
him like an Angelic kind of being that's
a good term for it but there were things
out there that seemed
have seemingly had never lived in this
Dimension they just lived over there
yeah all right so let me get back to
this so we don't so we're not here all
night go rest okay um okay so another
thing that they did in this Warehouse
was um
Julio's fiance's dad whose name was Jose
Diaz he was also something of a medium
or at least he called himself that so he
actually had a he had a good idea he
said I'm going to bring in some kind of
similar items to the stuff that gets
broken all the time like the beer signs
and stuff except I'm going to bring in
ones that are like similar to that but
are not breakable and I'm going to put
them in the same area and see what
happens so he did that uh but turns out
that the Poltergeist instead just broke
[__] somewhere else that was breakable
and just left that stuff where it was so
you know Poltergeist was smarter than he
was
apparently um also they brought in a
skeptic which I'm always uh kind of a
fan of in these situations and um this
is good because the skeptic that they
brought in was a magician Howard Brooks
I always am a big Advocate because I
liked James Randy and all that kind of
stuff um if you're going to have
somebody investigate a haunting or a
poltergeist SE please please please uh
or if you're doing a Paras pych parasal
study of someone of like PK or something
like that please bring in a magician
because um they know all the [__]
tricks like how to fake stuff uh and
they've caught a lot of people doing
what they thought was like pretty clever
chicks but but we not going to um you're
not going to fool a magician because
they know all that stuff so they bring
in this magician Howard Brooks um now he
comes in and he just thinks well you
know obviously this is all fake somebody
is faking this so he came in and um he
actually saw a couple of heavy well not
heavy but they were like 4 lbs each like
boxes and he he saw them like move
across the table and slide off like
nobody pushed it and he saw a couple of
other things and later he apparently had
to admit he like yeah well if somebody's
faking it I don't know how they're doing
it like I can't figure it out so there
was
that now at this point because they
thought Julio was the
focus um William roll sent him for some
psychological tests and like personality
assessments and stuff like that now
probably not too surprisingly it was
found that Julio really did not like his
job and really did not like his boss and
um was just a very angry person in
general um and very unhappy and um he
kind of seemed
like they asked him at one point they're
like do you think that you were
unconsciously causing all of these
phenomena um he seemed offended by this
question but he did admit that all of
this stuff breaking everywhere um kind
of made him happy yeah you know what I
mean thought it was awesome yeah he
thought it was kind of awesome that like
all this stuff was break because he
really really hated this job before I
forget if you're listening to this uh
show recorded U if you're enjoying the
show please make sure to uh do us a
favor and uh give us a what do they call
it a super thanks a like or a comment or
super thanks anything will be every now
and then we get a super thanks every now
and then yeah yeah um so yes so they
asked him all these questions and they
also found out that his personal life
was also something of a mess he lived
with his stepmother she was like you
need to get the [__] out of the house so
she was trying to kick him out and he
was going to be homeless um and he was
actually uh suicidal he was having like
really bad nightmares [__] like that um
and they noted that a lot of the his
feelings like this that he had reported
um started about 10 days prior to the
Paranormal Activity starting at the
warehouse also um on January 30th which
was probably about I think it was like a
month and a half after the phenomena had
started uh there was a break-in at the
warehouse overnight uh some petty cash
was taken and a few other things um and
they immediately suspected Julio and
when they questioned him he did confess
to doing that the manager didn't press
charges um but they did fire him
now the police sergeant that
investigated this the crime said to the
manager allegedly that Julio admitted
that he had been causing the Paranormal
Activity that he had' been throwing
stuff around himself um that he had tied
thread around stuff and was like pulling
it off of the shelves and everything
like that but the cops didn't find any
um thread and the parapsychologists that
were there didn't find any thread the
magician that was there they didn't
really find any evidence that that was
the case tolds that tells me that he
didn't believe the phenomenon was real
maybe not yeah so that would help him do
it more because you know you got to
believe it's an outside
force thought it it's all [__] I did
that [__] yeah yeah I did it with
thread yeah it it could possibly be that
because he seemed kind of like a messed
up person like a little bit yeah and
he's trying to take credit for it
subconsciously because his subconscious
knows that he did do it but consciously
he thinks he's lying he's trying to say
yeah I hurt you yeah but he thinks he's
lying he isn't he's telling the truth he
did it but he didn't do it thread right
so I see what he did I mean [__] how
how committed to this chicanery would
you have to be to like tie threat around
like hundreds of different items people
would see you exactly see that's what I
mean they I mean they observed things
happening like hundreds of times yeah
people would see them without him doing
anything he didn't do with thread no he
didn't know he didn't know that he was
behind it he was trying to take credit
for now some people that have like said
that they had telekinesis and like were
in a laboratory have used thread because
they've caught them yeah easy to catch
so it is a very common thing that they
do but uh nobody seemed to have seen
that going on and like I said that would
seem like you know considering the
magnitude of the manifestations in this
case um that would have taken somebody a
really long time to pull that off you
know you'd have to be real committed and
I just don't see like some 19-year-old
pissed-off Guy having the wherewithal to
tie thread around a bunch of stuff and
like pull it like why would you do that
I don't know you'd have to be a crazy
person um so so yeah so they did fire
him now interestingly after they fired
him which was February of
1967 all of the Paranormal disturbances
stopped
immediately which just goes to show um
now after he got fired from tarp
propagation Arts he got
arrested because he was stealing an
engagement ring uh for his pregnant
girlfriend from under L from a jewelry
store so she was pregnant yeah his
girlfriend was pregnant so he's worried
about that yeah right uh he got six
months so you know they didn't give
locked him up six months they were kind
of easy on him I guess but for the theft
yeah now I I will say the Paras
psychologists uh Dr R and Dr Pratt um
they heard about what happened to him
and they uh rais money for a grant um
because they wanted him to undergo test
like PK tests and ESP tests and stuff
like that to see if maybe he had some
kind of like gift or something he would
have done good right um he didn't want
to do it though okay he didn't want to
be he said he didn't want to be their
guinea pig yeah he's an [__] yeah
yeah that's how he's doing I mean he was
19 or 20 at this point so you know what
I mean like young guys that age are
always kind of like that yeah he would
have guessed a lot of stuff right had he
had good uh uh instinct about what
people were thinking and you know like
if they do the cards thing I would have
done well on that test probably back
then yeah probably real well yeah above
I would have done above random at least
when I was in full-blown [__]
Poltergeist mode at like [__] 13 that
probably would have [__] been real
impressive probably would have only been
for a certain amount of time though for
like a couple weeks when all that was
happening but I would had to have think
that the ghost was telling me to do it
yeah that the ghost showed me that kind
of thing Tony Tony Tony showed me things
that's what he's talking about yeah yeah
yeah you would had to little like that
yeah talking to Mrs T yeah which that's
where that's where all that came from
the shiny came from
that well yeah Stephen King reading
about this sure well like I said that
was very big in the 60s and70s like I
read a bunch of books about that yeah
he's not doing anything [__] he's not
making anything up he's reading what
parapsychologist are saying yeah cuz
like I read a lot of those books too so
that's where he's getting ideas that's
where to deny it fic writers get ideas
from that to deny it and put it on
something else makes it a lot
easier that might go back through that
might go back a long time ago maybe some
of those witches were real maybe some of
them were just psychics and the whole
idea that and they thought their
familiars were talking to them and it
was actually kind something more like
boltergeist
possibly the information they were
getting through their familiars was the
same thing like
Tony yeah or the Poltergeist it's
something else that's doing
it and then they see that once or twice
in the Medieval Era and it freaks them
out so bad the church says we got to
hunt these things down and Destroy them
and then the whole industry pops up
around it I could see that happening
yeah because they believed
it but what was weird is that every now
and then some of the reports that they
gave if the reports are real you can't
tell if it's might be a modern report
dressed up to look like an old report
that they put in it's called an
interpolation they might be
interpolating putting [__] in the
records that aren't old it's new but
it's made to look old there may be some
of that in there but some of the some of
the old cases that I heard sound like
Poltergeist but they were saying it was
witches right well that's how they would
have interpreted in the context of the
time yeah if that really happened or if
it was a modern person put that in the
record saying yeah polter guys witches
that's what they're talking about Zach
says so what Tom is saying is that he
has a tiny man who lives in his mouth
that's hot look at this [__] I had no
idea Tom was into War Z bad [__]
you and then he goes down to his
stomach you know what like the first
time I saw The Shining when I was a kid
like I don't know why that freaked me
out so much but that when Danny says
it's like he's the little man that lives
in my mouth that [__] freaked me the
[__] out you're not talking yeah well
where is he why can't I see him he goes
down he hides yeah he hides yeah
that little kid was so good in that
movie he's talking about his he's
talking about the his subconscious yeah
self and its psychic
ability that was another if you guys
didn't read the book Tony was Danny it
was an older it was an older version of
Danny that was helping him which they
made very clear in the in the book well
in the book and in the shitty miniseries
yeah yeah the shitty miniseries yeah the
shitty miniseries they made it very
clear because Dan like because Tony
came to him like as a floating teenager
floating teenager with glasses with
glasses that was talking to him and I'm
like that is so lame it was it was just
so much better in the Stanley kuer
version where he was just like he would
see him floating be Point he'd be that
was so much creepier you'd see him
floating and he'd be pointing at the
clock or pointing at dates and [__]
trying to show him stuff and he couldn't
understand all of it yeah it's just well
well like I said and I think I've
pointed this out before this is the
reason that I really not like the mini I
love the book don't get me wrong I
really did not like the miniseries
version which was what 97 the miniseries
version of The Shining that that Stephen
King did um because it was too literal
it was exactly like the book yeah and
[__] that works in the book The book's
amazing yeah [__] that works in the book
doesn't work in a movie no much better
to do go the Stanley kubri rout and make
everything like ambiguous and only the
way you would see it if you were there
and like you don't have any context for
it much scarier if you want to know what
the book says and you don't want to see
the book though just see the TV series
cuz it's pretty much exactly pretty much
exactly what was in the book but like I
said that's it just it doesn't play as
well it doesn't work as well those are
two completely different mediums and you
really
can't
translate that to that's why I mean man
the Stanley CER version is so much
better it's just so much more ambiguous
and it's so much scarier the king didn't
invent any of that [__] Paras
parapsychologists thought about these
Concepts and trying to piece it together
way back into the 60s sure and uh the
whole uh inner denial and making the
Poltergeist and psychic phenomenon an
outside agent that's doing this and it's
not you it's something else it's a ghost
or it's something or it's a familiar uh
that's s by by demons or Satan or [__]
like that that's
all [__] basically what what king was
talking about with [__] Tony which is
uh the subconscious mind is kind of like
in a super ego it knows more than you
because the subconscious mind isn't
Limited in the same way but it also
doesn't have all the same things your
awaking Consciousness has but it's it's
in a way more powerful and it can it can
face the truth a lot better than your
conscious mind your conscious mind is
mostly a defensive mechanism more than
else make you feel better about what's
going on what's going on your
subconscious knows the truth it has
better spatial awareness and it has more
accurate Judgment of other
people and it has access to information
that the conscious mind shouldn't have I
think it's some kind of quantum
Consciousness the Consciousness that's
encoded in the universe throughout
SpaceTime so you might have some access
to feelings and knowledge about the past
in a certain area you're in or if you
wanted to know something you can might
be able to access remote knowledge your
subconscious might through
Transcendental Meditation you can do it
in a meditative State and get Visions
which is like like
that but um yeah King's take in the book
is say pretty accurate because he's just
copying what Paras
thought yeah Tony was just daddy older
trying to explain to him the danger of
what was going to happen at the at the
at the hotel like I said he could see
the future I'm glad that they left that
ambiguous and he had access to the
future he knew it was coming which you
know animals are like that too I believe
I believe that they can do it they just
we see it as Instinct but animals might
have premonitions of the future feelings
they're shown things of what might
happen but I don't think they're aware
consciously aware of what what's doing
it just feeling it's just feelings it's
not a it's not a highly evolved
Advanced feature that a person can do
it's primitive which I think people I
think that wigs people
out Poltergeist feels and and those
abilities feel primitive to me not
Advanced
yeah all right so where was I so okay so
Julio didn't want to be tested at least
at first um he married his
girlfriend and they had uh a baby they
had a baby girl now Julio went on and
worked at a bunch of other kind of
shitty jobs and reported
the manifestations followed him to some
of those workplaces but I don't think to
the same level or same
intensity um a month after his daughter
was born Julio was working at a gas
station and there was a robbery and he
was shot three times damn uh he lived uh
even though one of the bullets um
severed his aorta but they were actually
able to fix it damn um the shitty thing
about it though was that he was so
injured that he couldn't really work
much afterward and I guess he didn't get
much disability uh so he fell into
poverty at which point he went back to
uh Roland um yeah he went back to the
Paras pychology and said okay I'll do
the parasca because they were going to
pay him right yeah but now he's not good
shap he went back to that now they gave
him some psychokinesis tests and he did
very well on those he did okay um but
the ESP tests no he didn't like uh they
said no better than chance okay now um
he actually told them that he could
control the psychokinesis but they
didn't see any evidence of that but he
but he did actually score high in the
test so there was that um so I don't
really know it seems like I don't know
what happened to him after that um when
I wrote the book he was still living in
the Miami area as far as I know but I
don't know what's happened to him since
then because how old would he be now um
well he was only 19 he was 19 in
1966 okay so he's old yeah so he would
be like an older guy now so I don't know
like what happened it kind of seemed
like he kind of was on track to have
kind of a shitty life which sucks now
you see these dudes didn't get a hold of
him when he was in good
shape you know what I mean he'd been
shot and uh and now all of a sudden he's
more aware of what it is that they're
trying to get out of him which kind of
taints his abilities you want him in his
like raw unadulterated form where he
doesn't really know even what they're
looking for that's that's what you
want so he wouldn't have been as good he
wouldn't have been a good test subject
at that stage he'd have been much better
before he got shot yeah I mean he just
came in there out of desperation CU your
physical injuries are going to affect
the mind yeah and apparently he was so
messed up that he couldn't work anymore
so right which is not going to put you
in the right state mental state has a
lot to do with it J knows I go into a
certain mental state it's more likely to
happen yeah but I'm not in that state
now and it takes months chill takes
months to slowly work into it it's not
as good as it was but takes months it's
not something you could do like in Star
Wars where you being attacked and you
just point at an object and throw it
like [__] Darth M did damn I wish you
could but no wouldn't that be awesome
although I would probably get in so much
trouble yeah I'd be flinging [__] at
every [__] yeah I don't think
yeah you piss me off poow yeah the thing
is though is that my will is not
superior to the will of somebody else so
if there's another if there's an
observer they might be able to stop it
you know I mean their [__] mental
disbelief of it could stop it right
that's why these guys prime the pump
sometimes and fake something to make it
easier yeah so if you're in Mortal
Combat with somebody that's totally
physical all those damn psychic
abilities go out the
window this all that psychic stuff
happens because you can't get physical
you can't get physical you're not in
that situation so it's trying to do it
through other means surreptitiously
yeah the military was into it they were
trying to [__] figure
out remote viewing and they got they got
[__] results project Stargate got
results about remote viewing but they
found out satellites are better
satellites and spies are much better
yeah well that's the thing any kind of
like human paranormal ability even if
they could prove it even if they it's
just not reliable enough you couldn't
depend on the intelligence that you got
from that because it's you know humans
are just very especially in a life and
death pinch you're under
attack that situation is calling for
physical force not some kind of damnn
psychic ability that's subtle it's not
what it's kind nebulous you don't really
know you don't know if it's right it's
like kind of vague it's like you know
it's not really you know I'm not saying
that people some people don't have it
it's just that it's not super useful in
situations like that going into some
kind of Astral state to go look and see
what kind of Submarine the Soviets are
built building you might get some pretty
good ideas you might be able to see some
of it but you wouldn't be able to prove
it right all right what's a lot better
is to just have some hot chick go down
and go screw some of those dudes who are
building that ship and Sh they'll tell
her everything that's called a sex
operative some [__] pictures of
that's the ultimate [__] the Ultimate
Weapon is a female sex operative for
that's what most of them damn spies are
because these dudes [__] they can't
keep it in pants dudes are dumb and
they'll tell you anything they can't
[__] keep it in their pants and they
start screwing some [__] he starts
bragging and just [__] blabbing his
whole you know I don't tell anybody but
I'm working on a secret sub oh I totally
won't tell anybody yeah yeah it's all
kinds of stupid [__] you
know see that's where that's where
that's where that Legend comes from that
dudes think with their dicks yeah they
do kind of well I don't well I don't
know if think is the word that I want to
use I don't think it's thinking that's
going on with the dicks they're not
thinking it just kind of turns their
brain
off not older dudes older dudes are
usually like WIS or that kind of [__]
but younger dudes man you can get them
to do all kinds of I lost a lot of
respect for the US Army when I was when
I was active when a friend of mine I saw
him and I said man where you been
where's your girlfriend he goes dude
that wasn't my girlfriend he goes what
he go she was a CID agent she lived with
me for [__] a year was sleeping with
that girl [__] and she was
investigating me cuz she thought the the
Army thought I was running a we a
marijuana selling ring that and I says
that was a [__] agent she goes yeah
it a c agent can you imagine and I was
thinking to myself that chick's in the
Army her parents are [__] proud as
hell of her right her job is to [__]
suspected drug
dealers yeah I would not I lost oh my my
girl she's so great [__] she was a
cute I thought she was a civilian she
wasn't a civilian she was a [__] an
army agent and he wasn't guilty he was
guilty of like little real little [__]
and they they just kicked him out they
didn't even send him to prison or
anything little weed stuff you know it's
like but he wasn't selling a big he was
a buyer he wasn't a [__] right he
wasn't living on post he was living off
post he wasn't doing it in while he was
working when he was
off but no when I found out that the
Army did that [__] they had [__] 22y
old girls in their [__] drug deal
or suspected to get information on them
right I was like man they're doing that
to people's
daughters yeah it's like who want that
job Somebody's Daughter I don't know
what that girl's rank was she might have
been a commissioned officer I don't know
she probably not old I'm sure she didn't
[__] sign up for that I'm sure
they're probably like hey you're doing
this now and she's like okay do I have a
choice no yeah so you know not great on
either end is it I'm sure she probably
didn't want to do that either I don't
know maybe she did maybe I don't know
maybe she was accused of something and
they leveraged her into it yeah maybe
they said you're going do this or you're
going to go or you're going to get in
trouble right well like I said that's
not really a choice either is
it yeah that's kind of forcing you into
yeah I lost a lot of respect for the
Army during that time well I will tell
you right now that I do not work for the
CIA yeah yeah you're not watching me
right no I'm
not I'm not watching you don't tell on
me i' have I'd have gotten bored a long
time ago Tom we've been together a long
time yeah and like I said I'm always
around I'm not doing anything yeah I was
just I was talking to my buddy Eric
about that you know cuz he knew the Dude
too he's like yeah that's [__] up and
he was one that brought up the dad thing
he's like imagine that her dad's proud
as hell of her and she he doesn't know
anything about what she does she's a
[__] for the Army basically yeah she go
they're probably sending her to all
kinds of suspected ass drug DS she's in
the middle of [__] gang bangs and
[__] I like yeah possibly yeah yeah and
they're probably paying cuz you got to
like [__] go along with it or I don't
know if she was a commissioned officer
or what that's messed up so and she was
doing drugs she was cuz like I said you
kind of have to because it's like
they're going to catch you she was
smoking weed with him right like the
same thing with like undercover cops and
[__] like that you have to do that stuff
otherwise they're going to be like oh
you're an undercover cop and then
they're going to shoot you in the face
so I just uh you know I just [__]
started to think of them as [__] scum
you
know down with that like I said that's
shitty on on both of them like the fact
that she was probably leveraged into
doing that and the fact that he was just
and he wasn't even doing anything that
any any any of these Intel agencies
[__] C which is that's the Army
version of the FBI or the CIA okay c
c FBI
CIA any intelligence Agents from any
company in any country scum scum
basically a criminal outfit well I mean
they have to be like I said because
they're kind of yeah nasty I mean that's
why we were doing you know I was like
people could argue that it's a necessary
evil but I don't I don't really know if
it is though it's not necessary it
didn't matter that dude they thought
that dude was selling weed it doesn't
it's like it's yeah it's different if it
was like somebody that was a [__]
serial killer or somebody that was like
a [__] sex trafficker or something
like that somebody that's just like
growing some weed who [__] cares
you're going to send these girls at
these drug these suspected drug dealers
why would you do that go B them in with
your [__] and [__] do all that and
have all these dudes and [__] all of
them that you can and [__] what kind of
woman is going to go along with this
[__] unless she's levered into it that's
what I mean I was like man the
Army women into that [__] maybe she's
just maybe they just pick them like oh
yeah she's a natural hoe we and then all
of a sudden and then it Dawns on you
wait a minute hold on you got
commissioned officers in the United
States saying this cheick here 21 is a
natural whor let's use her that's
another thing that's like where the
[__] morale honestly that would not
surprise me at all yeah it's like hey we
could use herle we could use this up
make find out all this [__] that these
dudes are doing meanwhile years lat she
[__] went up there and little did her
little testimony against him and they
got him kicked out of the army and
[__] he's up there and it's a it
wasn't even her name she didn't even
look at him she he he lived with her for
about a year that's crazy slip slept
with her and everything and he didn't
even know she was military thought she
was a civilian right that's crazy she
was a hippie chick that was her [__]
cover yeah see that blows my mind that
like that that must be really hard on
people that have to do like undercover
[__] like that yeah I can never do
anything like that they never deci her
name cuz they didn't want her name he
they didn't want him to know her name
the court knew her name he didn't know
her name cuz I'm just so she under
protection I'm just like such an open
person yeah like to the point of TMI
sometimes so it's just like I have a
hard time like pretending to be yeah
something else you know what I mean I'm
not good at Deception I'm not good at
anything like that I just never saw the
point of it you know yeah I see these
people that like lie about stuff all the
time it's like that just seems like work
yeah you have to construct all we we got
to we got to get back to the yeah I know
I we haven't even talked about Donnie
Decker yet well Don Decker is the next
thing we're going to talk about it's Don
Decker and it's two short ones okay okay
so you think you can handle that I might
need another drink though okay so like
while you're gone do you want me to
start or you want me to wait go ahead
and spill some time with yeah I mean you
know about this case kind of so we're
going to talk about Don Decker otherwise
known as the Rainman the Stroudsburg
brainman um or the brain boy I've heard
that too even though he's he wasn't a
boy when this really happened but yeah
so this a pretty famous case uh it first
happened in
1983 I didn't actually hear about it
until about 10 years later it was on
Unsolved Mysteries and I remember it
made like kind of a big impression on me
and he was actually on there like being
interviewed so this was a kind of a
strange case of um there's not a lot of
these but there are some um a
poltergeist cases that were like water
manifestations like I said I wrote a
book with Steve Mara who's a a British
parapsychologist and he did a case in uh
that happened in rdale Manchester and um
where they had rain inside the house and
this was kind of similar but Don Decker
is unusual because
allegedly he learned to control it at
some point although I don't know I don't
know what's happened to him since he got
out of jail which we'll talk about later
but um he could apparently control it
for a little while uh but I I don't
think he can do it anymore you know what
I mean uh because the circumstances that
it started manifesting and were uh
unusual you know so it's uh late winter
1983 uh don Decker who was 21 years old
at the time um he was in County Jail it
was a kind of a minor charge it was just
like receiving stolen property something
like that so he was on it was 4 to 12
month sentence
now February 24th they gave him a Furlow
because his grandfather had died and he
was going to go to the funeral uh his
grandfather's name was James khaw I
think is how you pronounce his last name
now so Decker goes to the
funeral and by his own account and he
said this on Unsolved Mysteries he
wasn't really expecting to have um the
kind of emotions that he had at the
funeral but when he gets there he just
do this whole like torent of emotions
like takes over um he wasn't sad about
his grandfather dying but allegedly his
grandfather had abused him since he was
seven years old and he had never told
anyone else in his family about it so
him showing up at this funeral seeing
his grandfather dead like lying in the
coffin seeing all his family and like
thinking about it like it's like
ruminating on it um sort of like broke
open something in his mind apparently
that's kind of how yeah there's sad over
a dude in honor and a dude who's dead
that was abusing him he's like he his
subconscious like no that dude's a
[__] monster yeah [__] that dud [__]
that dude what are you honoring that
dude for so yeah yeah I can see how you
would and like I said he was fairly he
was 21 at the time which is still pretty
young so I can imagine and H and having
kept it secret all of that time yeah um
would have really been that would have
really [__] you up as
well now um Don Decker and his mom were
not speaking at this point um so he
couldn't stay at her house like over the
furo so he stayed with like Friends of
the family whose names were Bob and Jean
kefir like uh over the few days that he
was home for the funeral um yeah they
kind of adopted him he was in prison at
the time they were yeah yeah yeah um
receiving stolen property yeah so they
gave him a few days fur yeah to go to
the
funeral um so these friends of the
family they they thought he was a good
guy you know he just you know fill in
with a bad crowd or whatever but he was
like fundamentally a good person so they
were a lot nicer to him apparently than
his real family were so he went and
stayed with them hi poy um so he went
and stayed with them like over the
funeral so he goes to the house they all
kind of chill out that
night and he sits he's sitting on the
couch in the living room and he said
that he started feeling what he called a
deep
chill and then he sort of went into like
a little bit of a trance kind
of now according to the kefir they said
that they looked over and they saw Don
sitting like real rigid on the sofa and
he just had this like blank look and
it's like he wasn't in there like you
know what I mean um and then they
noticed that the room went really really
cold and then Water started dripping
down the walls and like out of the
ceiling a little bit like it started
like drizzling in the house
essentially so at this point um as you
would they thought that maybe a pipe had
burst or something like that um Bob
apparently was pretty familiar with the
layout like of the plumbing in the house
and he's like the water was kind of
showing up in places where there weren't
any pipes Behind the Walls he was pretty
much 100% sure but he decides well you
know just to cover all the bases I'm
going to call the landlord whose name
was
Ron and uh have him come over and have
him have a look see and see what's going
on so Ron shows up and um he's kind of
looking around and he's just as confused
as everyone else is uh they said at this
point the rain inside the house was
falling quite heavily and was also
starting to ooze up through the
floor um Don was sitting there on the
couch and he was just kind of still in
this trance he zoning out yeah yeah he
was kind of zoning out he would have
like sometimes come out of it but he
just kind of seemed that's kind of the
way I was when that thing flew right
yeah like what Happ yeah he was like
what where yeah like that so that's kind
of what he was like so they didn't know
what to do so Ron and the Keers who were
living in the house um they call the
cops so two cops show up um they come in
and they get rained on inside the house
I mean they both reported they walked in
and it was just and they were both
soaked um they also both reported that
they saw um droplets of this water like
just kind of hovering in midair and
moving
horizontally um floating yeah and one of
the cops said that it freaked him out so
much that he said he just felt all the
hairs on his NE standing up so they knew
that it wasn't like normal paranormal
[__] yeah they knew it was
paranormal um and then they noticed Don
sitting there like in a trance or
whatever zoning out and they said well
why don't you take him out of the house
for a bit and we're going to stay here
and see if we can figure out what's
going on so Ron who is the landlord he's
like well I'll stay in the house with
the cops you guys go someplace else so
the keyf first take on to this pizza
place yeah um which is owned by this
woman whose name was pam pam
scrafano and when they walk into the
pizza place they said okay so two things
happened like they they figured this out
later at the
house Ron and the cops said that the
cold in the house and the rain like
stopped the second that Don left the
house as soon as he left it stopped yeah
but in the pizza
restaurant it started in there okay like
like water started coming down from the
ceiling and like pudd ing up on the
floor like as soon as Don came in and
sat down so he brought it with him where
right that's what the lady at the
restaurant said yeah okay and I got some
questions I don't know if you have in
there the water at the house how much of
it was pulled up on the ground when it
was when it was over did they actually
say oh I don't know okay like was it was
the carpet swimming in it or was it just
damp yeah I don't know I mean I'm
reement show it was wet right like it
was like it had been raining in there
I mean all of the reports that I saw
they said it was it was like it was
raining in the house yeah so I'm
assuming it wasn't like a flood or
nothing but it was probably like the
carpet was like kind of saturated that's
kind of the impression that I guess the
water dries normally it doesn't vanish
it dries up normally right seeps away
over time so that means there's water
damage after this although interestingly
in the rdale case which is kind of
similar to this that happened in England
um they reported that it's like the the
it would the rain would come down from
the ceiling and then when it would stop
it would just kind of go and it would
just kind of like dry back up dry back
up yeah like back into the ceiling like
it was super weird I remember I've seen
these police um the cops that were in
the house I've seen interviews with
them they were freaked out yeah the cop
said that after it happened they they
had to go back to work they left he said
that that [__] bothered him for a
long long time he couldn't stop thinking
about that said he said it was he said
it was Eerie very eerie he said said he
knew it wasn't normal and I think they
also said that the the water wasn't
quite normal the the water was a little
bit sticky a little
thicker Steve said that in um rdale too
did he said the water was a little bit
little bit thicker I wish they would
have gotten a little some sample of that
and have that
analyzed that water was being pulled out
of the [__]
nothing he's making water molecules so
somehow using psychokinesis which is
crazy it makes me wonder because the
texture maybe it wasn't really all water
maybe some of it was water some of it
was heavy
water which is you
know to a dude who's just making water
using psychokinesis he doesn't know much
about [__] atoms you know hydrogen
atoms so he makes he just starts making
a bunch of [__] that's kind of like
hydrogen atoms right one of them would
be heavy water that's what you use in
like nuclear plants and I think it is a
little heavier it's got It's got an
extra what is it it's got extra
electrons on it or something I can't
remember more protons and neutrons
remember that stuff right might more
protons than
neutrons and uh there might be a bunch
of impurities in it I'd like to get like
a scientific analysis of it to see how
accurately he was making water yeah
maybe he was making water very
inaccurately it's waterish it's water
like
[Laughter]
substance yeah that's weird
probably a compound of a bunch of stuff
water heavy water other things that are
more like oil you know but but they
evidently they didn't
separate I'd like to see what it was it
may have not actually been all
water weird Z says I'm surprised they
never made the Decker case into a movie
because I think it'd be awesome in aome
it probably would he said I think the
Poltergeist case that freaked me out
most from your book was the one about
the flamethrowers coming through the
power socket in Chicago was yeah I think
that was Chicago yeah yeah like that
like all the Flames would come in and I
think that was pretty shortlived too but
it's like that was kind of the main
manifestation was just like fire coming
out of the [__] sockets I remember
that one these water ones freak me out
though yeah we go ahead and plug the
book Jenny wrote a book and she if you
like these cases that book how many
cases in that book hundreds right yeah a
couple hundred she tracked all hundreds
of these cases down and gives them all
in a book called unseen hand the Unseen
hand and it's uh you can find it on
Amazon Jenny Ashford yep Amazon unseen
hand and you it's aail also available on
audio book yeah I did an audio book
right she you can listen to Jenny she'll
read the whole book to you she got a
nice soothing voice not like now not
like
now not like me bring me a Scots now you
sound like a
duck quack quack quack I do
not yeah well like I said in a way we
were talking about this the other day I
said I kind of like the the old broad
yeah you know what I mean like whatever
happened to Baby Jane kind of voice yeah
you know bring Mom a cigarette a lot of
people see Jen you know some of the old
shows we first started don't realize
that that Jen was in her 40s then she
looks like a kid and she sounds like a
kid but she was in her 40s then yeah I
think well [__] when we met I think I
was 38 yeah yeah I'm pretty sure I was
38 years old when I met you I think I
was like 41 yeah 40 41 Zach says I think
a deeper voice suits your look more
Jenny yeah okay okay like I said I'm not
that bothered about it it's just kind of
funny we were watching a video earlier
with like a she's kind of like a
bodybuilder she's not like a big you
know big body like a fitness model
fitness model um that Tom follows yeah
bakar naiva and she has a well I don't
know like the same sounding voes me are
slightly deeper deeper and it's weird
how shitty um dudes are in the comments
like saying o is that a man she does not
look like a man by any stretch of the
imagination [__] smoking hot yeah
smoking hot she's really feminine
looking yeah and she acts real feminine
and I don't think her voice is that
masculine sounding either so it's like
well I think dudes are just like
intimidated and they're just like making
shitty little comments thinking well
they know they can't get her yeah her
boyfriend I didn't want her anyway cuz
she looks like a man but even though she
doesn't she doesn't sound like a man
either no no I've seen photographs of at
least a dude she was dating back then
who's a [__] that dude weighed 230
pounds of [__] pure muscle I mean
when she's standing next to him she
looks all woman because that dude is
[__] Superman all right I think she's
beautiful yeah so those dudes [__]
can't get it and they got a hate on her
and she's in better shape than them well
yeah that's why they're hating on her
yeah they're just hating on her she's
doesn't have big arms or anything she's
got nice arms [__] nice by slender
ripped and big muscle booty and thighs
that's her [__] calling card she's
got a [__] super muscular booty but
that's why see Tom always tries to make
me feel better by going look at this
girl she has like a deeper voice than
you have and yeah there's lots of them
like I said I'm not it doesn't bother me
that much but people have commented on
it yeah but I don't know I'm not that
bothered I'm I'm too old to give a [__]
what anybody thinks about me at this
point those those girls are all on gear
and they're all porn stars or actresses
or fitness models all those girls are on
gear if anybody tells you that they only
a few of them I think are natural but in
general if those girls [__] shredded
and they got [__] six packs of [__]
they're on
gear they're on gear a woman really
can't a woman beyond the age of 15 or 16
can't maintain that they just the
androgens aren't there I don't even
think a 15-year-old could get a [__]
a real
six-pack I don't think so they got a lot
of hormones in them but probably not
enough to get that lean and to get build
that much
muscle those little gymnast girls in the
Olympics that do all that [__] bouts
and look see those legs they're on gear
they got that little girl on gear
they're just not on gear when they're at
the Olympics when they're training them
[__] are on Prim Prima
bowling all right can we get back to the
[__] now so we can like finish the stuff
up okay I I don't want you to go off on
a whole yeah I'm going off on that [__]
on that whole thing'll talk all night
about that yeah all right so um so yeah
so where we so so he's at the pizza
place now the lady that runs pizza place
she was freaking out because she thought
he was possessed or some [__] so she had
a crucifix like you do and she pushed it
on him and Don said it was burning him
so you know very Exorcist at this point
so the Keers are like okay well we need
to get get you out of here so they got
him out of the pizza place hope
hopefully they paid after they left all
the phenomena in the pizza place stopped
obviously so they go back to the house
the keir's house the cops are still
there Ron's still there Ron's wife has
showed up her name is romae like the
lettuce but not spelled same um as soon
as Dawn comes back to the house it
starts raining in there again and then
everybody starts hearing like all the
pots and pans and [__] in the kitchen
like rattling
together and at this point Ron the
landlord he goes up to Don he's be like
what are you doing cuz he thought it was
a prank you know what I mean he thought
like Don was [__] with them so he's
like look you're causing damage to my
property um so knock it off
but apparently what happened after this
was that everybody that was there which
was included two police officers they
said that Dawn levitated a couple inches
off the ground and then was thrown back
against the wall yeah you know what I
mean like he just went pow like against
the wall like that like a bunch of
people saw that they said yeah I think I
think that that woman saw that which
woman the woman that was taking care of
was it his mom was his mom or was it the
uh the girl the woman he was staying
with no the um yeah the couple that he
was staying with were there the landlord
and his wife were there and two cops
were there yeah and they apparently all
saw this they saw him levitate and be
thrown against the wall like with
obviously nobody
there now so the two of the cops that
have been there they left for a little
while and they brought the police chief
back cuz like I said you got to see this
[__]
probably now um the police chief comes
he gets rained on when he comes in the
house just you know CU [__] coming out
of the ceiling and he said that he saw a
weird Mist that was like hovering in the
living room yeah now he told the two
officers um don't file a report because
this is just a plumbing problem he said
I think he was in denial probably he
just wanted it to be that and yeah and
the officer said that too they thought
that he was just in denial because he
was just like I don't know what this is
so I'm just like trying to like put it
in the box say what are you going to say
yeah you're not going to put you're
going that in a record people wouldn't
believe it right that's what that's what
he came up with the Mist he saw the
weird Mist that's must have been where
the psychokinesis maybe was condensing
the water or a part of it weird wish I
were to see
it yeah pretty cool cool ability now
when he got
thrown Donnie kept seeing he in the
interviews he says he keeps seeing the
face of an old man laughing at him and
the old man has a crown and I take it
it's his grandfather Yeah cuz he said he
went up to the bathroom like after the
funeral in in the keir's house and like
he saw the old like a the old man's face
like reflected in the window or the
mirror or something like with a crown on
Crown and he started getting scratches
on his forearms of crowns that's right
crowns and um in the interviews he never
says it's his grandfather but it's
implied that that the old man is his
grandfather or a representation of his
grandfather at some point cuz it does
seem like there was some kind of like
problem there it's is what caused all of
this yeah you know what I mean um so
yeah so the other two comps were like
okay well obviously the chief just
doesn't want this to be paranormal like
despite what he's seeing so they did
leave but then the next day they were
just kind of like we got to figure out
what the [__] is going on with this they
got two of their other two other cops
they're like come on you have to come
see this so they got two more and then
they went back to the house even though
the chief told them not to but they're
like we're we're going to do it anyway
because we got to see what the [__] is
going on so there are four cops in the
house now now by the time they get to
the house this is the next day um
there's still some phenomena going on
but it's kind of like lessened somewhat
now there wasn't any weird rain on that
day but there were a couple of other
weird things um apparently one of them
handed Don because they had heard about
the pizza place incident with the
crucifix so one of them handed him a
crucifix and apparently it burned his
hand
um and then when he took it back it
wasn't like hot or anything you know
what I mean so it was like I said very
Exorcist um also that day they said they
saw another
levitation thing incident of him yeah
Don got uh picked up a couple inches off
the floor and then thrown backward like
I said again so they so four of them
said they saw it um one of them said and
this is a quote uh it was as though a
bus had hit him yeah and also said that
they saw like claw marks like three claw
marks like on his neck like while that
was
happening um and all four of the cops
apparently saw this and couldn't come up
with any explanation for
that um so the landlord at this point um
after he saw a bunch of this stuff like
I said at first he thought Don was just
like playing a prank or something like
that but after he saw some more stuff he
started to feel sorry for da and decided
he was going to try and like help him
out so he starts calling around to see
if he can get an exorcism going um this
is why he's still on Furlow right um
yeah cuz this was only like he I don't
remember how many days it was like
several days that he was on Furlow I
think it was like over a long weekend or
something um so yeah so they can't
really get a Catholic priest in there
but they finally get some preacher to
come in and he's like yeah I'll come in
and do like an exorcism me kind of thing
so they come in there and he does all
the prayers and everything like that now
now during this exorcism light or
whatever yeah um Don starts
convulsing uh but apparently uh you know
as the prayer started getting more like
he stopped doing that so he just got
some church people to come over they got
some CH church people to come over and
um this apparently like it had been kind
of raining and cold in the house like
the whole time but as the prayers went
on it started like getting less and less
so um and then Don starts to slowly
return to his normal self like I said
this is going in a very Exorcist kind of
Direction well like I said before pure
guy sometimes looks like possession
right but a subconscious mind attacking
him yeah he must had a lot of inner
guilt he thought he could have stopped
it but he probably could have stopped
the
abuse well yeah and I I feel like that's
pretty common especially with children
that have suffered abuse by a family
member they always kind of feel like
they like it's their fault somehow could
have been that he's also regret not to
not have
told that too because I don't think I
don't think the rest of the family knew
about no he said he didn't tell anybody
and it had been going on for years and
years yeah like since he was seven years
old right so and like I said again
that's very common and that's really
shitty because kids kind of well kids
are um the center of their own universe
so anything that happens to them they're
going to think that they're to blame
somehow yeah you know what I mean um and
it's really hard well you know kids like
their parents get divorced and it's like
oh it was something I did you know what
I mean and obviously it wasn't he didn't
say his granddad was mean to him so
maybe he felt like he was
complicit right that too and like I said
that's very common that's very common
with kids that are um yeah that are
victims of abuse like that um but yeah
so so everything seemed fine until Don's
furo was over so he had to go back to
jail he was in the county jail to do the
rest of the sentence and so when he's in
jail I guess he's kind of bored and he's
like like maybe I can actually like
control this [__] so he decided to try
and do that this is the only guy I've
ever heard of that I believed that said
he could actually at will control the
phenomena I wasn't able to do it yeah
and well call it on but once it's on I I
it does what it wants to do it'll
respond to requests but it's always
stupid [__] move this over there that
kind of stuff yeah that was back when I
was a kid it didn't respond to anything
last time it was around yeah it just did
wanted like when you weren't thinking
about it yeah just at the drop of a hat
like you'd be forgetting about it and
You' do it it's down it in here but it's
very
minor yeah and it's nothing you it's
nothing intentional no it's like a side
effect yeah like when you're think fly
right [__] like that yeah so he decides
so he sits in his jail cell and he's
like I'm going to concentrate on the
[__] and
evidently um kind of like rain started
dripping from the ceiling of the cell
like kind of running down the walls and
stuff so a guard's walking by and sees
water on the floor and so he thought
that Don was just like throwing water
around like from the sink or the toilet
or whatever and Don's like no I can
actually make it rain like with my mind
and the guard is like yeah sure you can
okay um yeah prove it why don't you make
it rain in the warden's office like if
you can do that so Don's like okay I
will
so he apparently closes his eyes the
guard walks down the hall and sticks his
head into the um of the warden who I
think was not like the main Warden but
he was just like the temp guy that was
in there and the warden sitting in his
desk and uh there was like a water patch
like right on his he hadn't noticed it
but it had come down from the ceiling
apparently and like soaked the front of
his shirt so the guard was like oh well
the guy down there said he could make it
rain in your office and it did
apparently because it's right there he
said I got him your yeah the front of
your shirt's all wet Don was like I got
him yeah so it's like yeah he told him
he got him first right he says no he
goes I I could hit him with some water
yeah he didn't say to make it rain in
there that's how that's not how I
remembered him telling the story he says
he said he told the guard says I can hit
the warden and he goes go ahead and hit
the ward say I'm hitting with some water
and he sat there for a second and he
goes I got him and they went over there
and [__] they found a water spot on
the ward yeah yeah I don't disbelieve it
at all so the warden after he hears the
show apparently he believed it because
they but they bring in the the priest
the
Reverend and um they're like see if you
can do something about this this fella
down here because we don't know what's
going on with that now at first the
Reverend was like uh no you're making
all that up or whatever and at this
point Don got really really mad at being
accused of
Faking and apparently according to
Witnesses when he got mad um his cell
filled up with this really bad smell no
not like a fart or anything like that
but like a really bad smell and then
like rain starts coming down the
walls so the Reverend at this point is
like okay well maybe there is something
to this yeah just trickled down he can
actually do this [__] yeah so he starts
praying with the
guy and this went on for hours and hours
and at the end of this ordeal uh don
start crying and starts talking about
all the [__] that had happened to him
like you know just like letting it all
out you know what I mean well rain rain
is symbolic for crying it's tears yeah
that's what he's doing yeah I kind of
feel I kind of got that impression that
he was that it was just like em motion
that he was bottling up because of like
I said because of the abuse that he'd
been going through and he couldn't like
express it and he wasn't um he was
estranged from his family like he didn't
talk to his mom or anything like that so
he didn't really have anybody to that he
could talk to about any of this stuff
so which is not good so yeah so he has
an hours long kind of like Epiphany like
he has an emotional breakdown or
whatever and um after that he seemed to
be a lot better um and the rain that had
been in the cell like kind of like dried
up and stopped now evidently Don wasn't
able to do the [__] after
that like at least as far as I heard
once he got it out of his system so what
yeah once he had this purge of like all
the emotions and then he confessed
everything and he said everything like
how he felt about everything and had
this big thing with the with the priest
or whatever like apparently it didn't
really do it anymore okay now he
confronted it as far as I know and I
don't know if he still thinks this and
this might have been a significant um
reason why he maybe could control it if
indeed he could was that he didn't
really I think to an extent he didn't
really believe it was him he thought
that it was the spirit of his
grandfather like [__] with him is
what he thought yeah that was his excuse
yeah like like he thought that his
grandfather was like like continuing to
abuse him like after he was dead once
once he admitted admitted to himself
that he was doing it he took
responsibility for it and the ability
vanished right that's kind of well that
was the same thing that happened in your
case basically yeah basically it can
come back but not as good as it did
before and it takes
months from well no I guess it doesn't
take months I gotta be a couple days
yeah if you're thinking about it a lot
and you're kind of in a particular St
worry about if you're worrying about I
got to worry about it yeah and then I
stop worrying about it and forget about
it and it'll happen and then it'll do it
yeah you then you could maybe start get
the ball rolling again but I never
wanted to get the ball rolling right
because you don't know where it's going
to end up like I said yeah and it's
easier if if you're afraid of
it the more fear you have of it the
better it goes kind kind of reminds me
of
like [__] [__] Yoda said and [__]
Empire Strikes Back [__] y the dark side
flows
easily you know [__] those abilities
come quick well yeah but you being
shitty is easy yeah being good is hard
well negative emotions are more natural
yeah they're they're they that's what I
said being [__] they're stronger and
they're more natural and they're more
rooted in [__] Primal fears which
that's what
that's what it is uh I guess you say nii
would call it the will you
know which the the dark side of the
force basically or that the dark side of
the force and the force are the same
things just different aspects of the
same thing n called it the
will the will to power or another he
said the ultimate manifestation of the
will is
growth just to dominate to grow to take
over and impose on other things that
everything imposes on other things even
inanimate objects imposing on other in
inanimate objects by occupying space
that other object should or could be
occupying but it isn't so that's what
life is to impose sure all right so um
so yeah as I said um it seems as though
his abilities vanished after he purged
himself of all the emotions um I first
heard about his case on Unsolved
Mysteries in early 1993 which is
probably where a lot of people heard
about it um sadly like he got kind of he
had a brief uh run with Fame like after
that because Unsolved Mysteries
everybody saw that [__] however uh
several years after his Fame had faded
somewhat in
2012 uh as Tom alluded to before he was
arrested on federal arson charges after
setting fire to a restaurant in
Pennsylvania um he actually turned
himself into to the cops but he said
that the owner of the restaurant had
paid him to burn the place down to get
the insurance money um so both the owner
and him were indicted on charges of male
fraud criminal conspiracy and use to
fire to commit a federal felony uh so
they were he was in there for a while
he's since been released but I haven't
heard anything about him since then I
think he was
released I want to say it was like four
or five years ago but it might have been
more recently than that but I haven't
heard anything about him since then but
like I said
not not necessarily like a super happy
life this guy has had much like the last
guy we were talking about but got to
have internal conflict that's well
that's kind of the point that we're
making is that you really have to be a
one a particular kind of person yeah and
two going through some [__] yeah because
like well everybody goes through through
some [__] at some point but you have to
be like a particular kind of person
that's going through some [__] at a
particular time in your life that's the
most tumultuous and then this stuff will
happen because it doesn't happen that
often element of faith that too I kindal
yeah cuz I don't think it would ever
happen to me because I don't really
believe that it would you got to have
faith you got to have a belief in
something outside yourself you got to
you got to be able to believe in the
Unseen right basically which yeah like I
said so I don't know if it would happen
to me because I'm
too I don't know I'm too rational for
that no you gotta be irrational that's
what I'm saying yeah instinctual you
know me I'm like I'm very Spock like so
it's not rationality it's emotion yeah
always all right so do you want to do
these two like yeah let's do the two
little ones yeah they're just they're
kind of short and they're kind of
similar in that both of these not only
had adults as the focus mainly
or didn't have a focus that they knew of
but also concerned um the spontaneous
appearance of blood yeah in the houses
which is had it happen rare but it does
happen it's got to come from somewhere
though yeah it's coming from inside one
of these people maybe it's just
teleporting a few drops out some of it
out well we'll see because yeah so this
one happened in France in
1986 so we have a truck driver named
Jean Mark I guess it's Bel May
so he moves into this house uh with his
wife Lucy they moved in in
1985 now they kind of renovated the
place um and you know they just thought
oh this is going to be our little dream
house or whatever now he was a truck
driver so he was away for a you know
long stretches of time so Lucy was by
herself in the house uh a lot now she
didn't mind it at first but after a
while um she started to feel like
someone else was in the house watching
her which you know is a very common
first manifestation before this kind of
[__]
happens now in early 1960 or 1986 rather
I was sorry I went a little [__]
backwards
there early 1986 she goes into the
kitchen of this house and sees a little
bit like something on the wall that kind
of looks like blood like just a little
bit
now she was just in there and she's like
look I just cleaned in here and I did
not see this but you know what are you
going to do it's not that weird it's
like oh maybe I smudged it I don't know
you know you're just kind of like not
thinking about it so she just cleaned it
up and they just like okay
whatever but then a little while later
she goes into the bedroom and sees that
this same blood looking [__] is on the
bed and on some of of her
clothes um which wasn't like that before
so she's kind of freaked out at this
point so she tries to clean it up again
thinking well there has to be some kind
of rational explanation for this right
that's what you would think however over
the next few days when she was at the
house by herself cuz like I said her
husband was
away um this stuff whether it was blood
or whatever it was starts appearing all
over the place like drops of it streaks
of it um the walls on the floors uh on
the ceiling and she would clean a place
and then turn her back and then turn
back and then there would be like smears
of it there so I guess it cleaned up
okay I guess leave stand yeah I guess
not good um there was also some other
Poltergeist activity going on too there
was like uh banging on the walls very
very common um yeah pieces of furniture
being moved around like while her back
was turned uh you know stuff would be in
a different place uh dishes were broken
doors opened put in closing by
themselves things like
that and um you know the blood would
appear and it started getting like worse
like there would be more of it you know
what I mean like bigger puddles or
bigger smears or whatever so she didn't
know what to do so she called the cops
now the first thing the cops show up and
they saw the blood and stuff but they
said well what must have happened they
had a dog so they said well maybe your
dog got hurt and was trailing blood
everywhere you know what I mean like
even on the SE cuz you know how dogs
walk on the ceiling sometimes but um
they found the dog they kind of looked
the dog over the dog was fine he didn't
have any Cuts or anything like that and
then they thought well well maybe
somebody's breaking into your house and
and making this mess or whatever so they
decide they're going to spread flower
around on the floor and see if
somebody's coming in and doing it like
you know to get their Footprints or
whatever so they do it overnight the
next day though there's no footprints in
the flower but there's still blood
spatters all over the house that were
not there the day
before so the cops take samples of the
blood uh they did tests on it this was
1986 you couldn't really do DNA on stuff
but they could determine that it was
human
blood Lucy also said that the door to
the cellar the basement um closed by
itself behind her and also one of the
cops said that he felt somebody tapping
him on the shoulder but when he turned
around nobody was
there so finally the cops didn't really
know what to do so they called like a
psychic or
whatever the psychic said as of course
because they always kind of say this
don't they they said oh there's a body
buried in the cellar and it's the ghost
so I mean apparently they believed the
psychic enough to like dig the Celler up
but you know not surprisingly they did
not find anything because like I said
that's what the psychic always says oh
there's somebody buried into of the
house you know I mean there might be but
not in this case um so at this point uh
Lucy and her husband husband John Mark
were um kind of like had it up to here
so they're like we're moving out of this
[__] place so they moved out now
their uh family came and moved in after
that and they you know at this point it
had started to get a little bit of a
reputation like it was kind of a small
town so everybody kind of knew about it
um and they called it like the blood
house or whatever or the bloody house um
but apparently the next people that
moved in did not have any problems at
least as far as I could determine so so
nobody really knows if she was the focus
if this was some kind of weird I mean
because that does seem like Poltergeist
activity does it not yeah it does
um and she was the only one in the house
when the [__] was going on so if there
was a focus then it had to be her or the
dog yeah because were the only living
being told there's something she was
worried about maybe so well like I said
it really does have to be some kind of
like emotional turmoil right yeah like
emotional was there something
reproductive did something reproductive
happen who knows did she did she
terminate a pregnancy something happened
we're not we're not like I said
something she lose a baby there we're
not being told
everything I mean possibly it's
possibly that's what I'm saying yeah her
age and
blood something reproductive maybe or
she was like worried about her period or
something something she was worried
about something reproductive possibly
manifested some kind of polised thing or
she watched too much True Crime [__]
whatever I don't really know no it had
something to do with
her but here the blood symbolized
something to her here's another one
though in relation to what she was
worried about that is similar but maybe
less explicable so this one happened in
Atlanta in Georgia where my sister lives
in
1987 and this is another case of a blood
Poltergeist now as far as I know this
house is still there I'm not sure of the
exact address you could probably found
find it if you looked up this is I don't
know if I'd say this a famous case but
it's fairly wellknown so it's kind of a
nice little house made of a brick in a
suburb of Atlanta now this house um this
couple had lived there in 1987 for uh 20
odd years and nothing weird had happened
their names were William and Minnie
Winston like I said they'd been married
a long time they'd lived there a long
time more than 20 years and nothing
weird had happened however in the fall
of
1987 Minnie's in the shower and kind of
gets out of the shower and sees that the
bathroom floor suddenly is covered
in red puddles that kind of look like
blood um and she kind of saw some of it
kind of coming out of the walls too now
Minnie was 77 years old at the time I
remember this case yeah and so she's
kind of freaking out like she didn't
think anything about oh it's
paranormal um she's like one these
puddles were not here before two she
thought that something bad had happened
to her husband William because he was
you know almost 80 he was 79 years old
and you know he wasn't in super good
health so she's like well [__] maybe he
you know came in and like bled
everywhere and like something's the
matter so she was like freaking out um
he had to have dialysis like he was on a
dialysis machine and he had to do it
like every day um so she starts yelling
for him like Hey like are you okay like
there's blood all over the [__] floor
and he shows up at the bathroom door um
and he's fine like he's in his pajama
he's like why what are you yelling about
you know what I mean I'm totally fine no
trace of blood
anywhere so the two of them at this
point they're like okay well obviously
something [__] weird is going on so
they started like looking around the
house and they're just starting to like
flip out because they can't figure out
where this came from right because she's
just been in the shower like nobody's
been in there so Not only was there
blood all over the bathroom floor but
there was blood all over the house like
there was like puddles of it like all
over the like in the living room and
[__] like that like down in the basement
um like even places where you couldn't
really get to like underneath the
appliances and like in the crawl space
and like coming out of the walls and
[__] like that like suddenly um what
they described it as they said it looked
like somebody had just like sprayed or
thrown blood all over the walls and the
floor they said that's what it looked
like like it looked like a [__]
murder scene right and like I said it
was in even in places where you couldn't
really get to like under the fridge and
whatnot so they didn't know what to do
they called the cops they like it looks
like somebody's been [__] murdered in
here we can't figure it out so the cops
come and again the first thing they
thought was that oh maybe like an animal
got wounded like a raccoon or something
and like got in here and like sprayed
blood everywhere yeah I remember this
but um but they looked around and they
couldn't find anything and then they
asked William they said well would your
cuz he had to do dialysis like I said
it's like well would that have you know
would you have gotten blood all over the
house and he's like look um one I I
wouldn't bleed any where he's like I I
don't even do the dialysis here I have
to go to like the medical center and do
it like I don't do it at home um you
know so I I don't know where all this
blood came from now so the cops took
samples of the blood and took it for
analysis a couple days later they found
out that the blood was human blood but
it was type O uh midi and William were
both type A H so it wasn't their blood
clearly but it was human blood but they
couldn't figure out where it came from
now at this point uh the story had kind
of gone around cuz like what bleeding
house right so that's kind of a big
story and um so there was a bunch of
stories in the media so they had like a
bunch of people like camping out on
their lawn and [__] like that now the
cops at this point actually declared the
house a crime scene um in part like to
keep people from coming in like and to
you know be able to like get them off
the lawn and what whatnot but also
because they were like there's so much
blood in your house that it looks like
somebody got murdered and until we
figure out you know if somebody got
murdered or not we really need to like
just close this [__] [__]
off so the cops went through everything
um you know they did an investigation
just that they would do like in a murder
or whatever um but they never could
figure out who the blood belonged to uh
or where it came from why it was all
over their house uh why it had suddenly
appeared with no Preamble what's
whatever um so after a while they
determined that no crime had been
committed they couldn't find a body or
anything like that so finally they just
had to close the case now nobody saw the
blood appear no it was just there it was
just there like I said Minnie was in the
shower she stepped out the shower and
there was blood puddle and then when
they went and looked in the house it was
just blood all over the place and none
was none was added after in other words
it wasn't more of it wasn't appearing as
I don't think so no and no objects moved
I don't think so no
it was just blood appearing everywhere
and then and these two like older people
well it's a bunch of blood that appeared
everywhere at once yeah it much
continuing to appear that's that's how I
read it anyway yeah but to say it's a
hoax maybe so must H it like I don't
know like why would two a 77y old and a
79y old so maybe somebody hoaxed them
perhaps it could be because that does
seem like somebody got some blood from
somewhere well they might have just
drained it from themselves what year was
this 86 86 yeah somebody might have just
drained the blood from themselves it was
a lot of blood though it's easy to it's
easy to put a [__] IV in drain some
blood maybe from a couple different
people your friends and sneak into the
old people's house and spread the [__]
around and then just sneak out the back
door or something like that that's
that's more likely than anything else I
wonder why somebody would do that though
what a weird thing to do CU it doesn't
follow any of
the patterns of poltergeist you know
repeated recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis constant moving of
objects demonstrational stuff patterns
right uh stacking stuff taking things
making things appear like where' that
come from you know whose pillow is that
you know that kind of [__] yeah whose
pannies are those yeah whose pillows
that you know it might have been from
the neighbor you dildo is that yeah just
anything [__] did you
J wishes all these free dildos to
[__] show up I've got lots of dildos
I don't need free one that's [__]
fun uh business dildos business dildos
yeah the tax write offs tax write off
dildos we just got one the other day
that's like super realistic it even has
balls and everything like like realistic
feeling ball it's pretty weird make a
video with that thing yeah although like
I said I'm not usually a big fan of like
realistic looking ones cuz I think
they're kind of weird but we're getting
off topic J well I mean well I was
pretty much done
now I do have the address I think it's a
hoax I do have the address of this house
but I'm not going to say it because I
would I mean you can find it probably if
I found it you can found it they either
hoaxed it for some reason or somebody
hoaxed
them you can get your hands on blood
yeah you know I kind of if this is a
hoax I kind of suspect that somebody
else did it to them for some reason
because I don't really see any reason
why this old couple that had lived here
for 20 plus years would suddenly decide
hey let's throw some blood around our
house and like call the cops crazy ass
16 17y old teenagers that knew these
broke in and Through Blood every well
they probably didn't have to break in
they probably knew these people maybe so
and [__] they just said this would be
funny man run through there and throw
this [__] blood yeah yeah that'd be
[__] you know you know you know what
I mean you know she when she's in the
shower going there and [__] cuz where
was the husband I don't know where the
husband was I think he was just in the
living room you could probably see her
in the sh hear the shower running from
outside the house if you're on the side
of the house you go she's in the shower
and then [__] she leaves her back
door open so you run there you and then
that's probably more and then they leave
with the with the [__] IV bag don't
do that to people it's probably what
they do and they did it in a way they
don't they're not walking through their
own tracks They started it one went into
the house and [__] so they put some
thought into this you're saying yeah
yeah probably that's more
likely cuz if it was a polter guy guys
you it would have been recurrent right
you know what I mean keep talking I got
a PE and it would have been it would
have done it as a demonstration right
you know it's not a onetime
thing that's the whole thing about
Poltergeist it's got like a
mission there's a reason why the why the
Poltergeist phenomena is
emerging out of this person and it's it
it it's it's trying to Comm communicate
and
demonstrate it's definitely
demonstrating what it can
do and it's uh it doesn't want to get
give up any information about what it is
and how it's doing
it it's trying to think you trying to
fake you fake you out and and make you
think it's an outside force because
that's what'll help it help it continue
what it what it's
doing and there's an overarching reason
for it it's either trying to break a
family apart or to bind a family
together or to [__] like in Donnie
Decker's case he's trying to expel all
his sadness from what happened to him
with his
granddad and finally once he confronted
it his sadness he resolved it he let it
out so he didn't have that internal
pressure and all that internal uh what
do you call it what's that conflict
built up in there he had resolved it so
his ility faded which that's unfortunate
in a way well it's fortunate for him
kind of unfortunate for me Donnie Decker
cuz I wanted I wanted to meet Don and I
wanted to see him make it rain and I'd
make it he could make it rain and I
could make it throw things or hide
things hi you could have like a little
Poltergeist party yeah we have a
poltergeist
party and [__] I say how' you how'd
you throw the water and you know and but
he thought that he thought that the evil
Crown man threw the water so so he did
it I mean that was my understanding that
he at least initially thought that it
was an outside for right like he thought
that it was a ghost yeah and he was
probably uh conflicted about that he
probably his subconscious knew but he
suspected it that it was him but he but
he couldn't believe that it was him
right so instead he lied saying that it
was him but he's
lying unknowingly he's actually telling
the truth
and then it finally resolved it said
yeah I am doing it and went
away well like you said we you have a
theory kind
of that you can't control it you have to
allow it and the best way to allow it is
to think that it's not you yeah like to
think that it's an outside that's that's
with any of that
stuff like the hardest thing about
having an out-of- body experience is is
that you have to allow it it's the
Ultimate Surrender you're literally
giving up the ghost so it's like
voluntary death it feels like death well
a lot of people resist death you're kind
of well yeah I mean that's a natural
reac natural thing as it comes you you
as as you start feeling the
separation you feel a loss of control
and then all of a sudden you feel like
you're P being pulled out and then
you're like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I almost died and it'll stop so
it's difficult it's extremely easy if
you just if you're just like a
kamakazi you know what I mean but I
haven't really been in that kamakazi
mode and then trying to allow it too
much trying too much imposes it you have
to suspend all
will yeah you can't try to do it it
doesn't work no you have to just total
surrender just [__] stop everything
and it almost feels like you're stopping
your mind you even stop thinking and
imagine that you're just going
everything's going
blank and uh then you feel like you're
ceasing to exist and then you'll be
looking down on yourself and you'll be
out and if you get too excited you'll
get sucked right back in
pow yeah I can see how that would be a
really difficult thing to do it's hard
to stay out yeah all the [__] about
silver cord and getting lost [__] I
didn't I didn't see any silver cord or
anything there's no problem going back
in the problem is stand out as soon as
you think of your body you go back yeah
if you just think about it you'll go
back and I was never able to go very
far because there were other people
[__] trying to [__] snap me out of
it in one case another case is that you
just you get out but then you lose
Consciousness then you wake up like you
were and you don't remember what
happened you wake up the next
morning like you remember looking down
on yourself right but then you you were
you were
exteriorized but then you fell asleep
while you were
exteriorized because it's partially
falling asleep with while maintaining
Consciousness right it's another way
another weird thing that it feels
like feels like your head's shaking back
and forth and then it gets stronger and
stronger stronger you just surad it to
it you're looking down and if you
[__] and you don't know the controls
you you just look at a place you'll go
there it's like you're on
a you're like a little ball that can see
like 360 and feels like you're standing
on a
[__] like a little spindle or
something a spindle like a stick and
just looking in the way you fall you're
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa and that
stabilizes and then you can choose how
you want to see things what you can
choose what colors they are you can
choose to look through things or to go
in things and look at something from two
directions at once you're
non-local and time is slowed down you
can do a lot in a very small it's like
compressed because you're not
being you're moving at the speed of
thought basically there's no physical
body to impede you so nothing takes any
time and you can you kind of have this
underlying feeling of just awareness and
you kind of you become aware of what you
can
do but there's so much stuff that you
can do you can't do it all in the amount
of time and then all of a sudden you go
man this is [__] amazing and then and
then you're back in right it's like that
the second you become like aware of yeah
you start becoming too aware of it or
you start getting too excited about it
and then you go woohoo I'm out of my
body you're like what happens you go as
soon as you whoa I'm out of my body you
think body and all then boom you're back
into it so it's hard it's like standing
on a
damn it's like riding on a pogo stick
and you don't really know how to ride on
a pogo stick or trying to [__]
balance yourself on on a stick anything
you do disturbs it and you want to go
somewhere or you go back into your into
your
body or you fall asleep and then you're
in Dreamland I think a lot of times
you're you're out of body when you're
dreaming you're just in a dream world
it's not a real world you know what I
mean yeah but you can see the material
world from that mind State just it
doesn't quite look quite the same you
can also see what other people are
dreaming you can go into their
dreams they'll see you and they'll
remember you if you know them but mostly
it's a person I don't know I just see
them at random dreaming and I see their
dream and I go in it it wakes them up
when they see
me I wrote a novel years ago that there
was like another dimension where all
like your nightmares came from you know
what I mean and it was like a place you
could actually go to yeah but see the
thing is is the the dream worlds are not
real they're more like a chat room
they've been created by a person you can
contact them there but they're in an
illusion
the other worlds are
real and you can see the material world
anything you want to see in the material
world you'll be you'll go there but you
may not see it very accurately right
it's kind of
vague everything just looks like [__]
uh geometric shapes of [__] particles
clouds looks like cigarette smoke you
know you know cigarette smoke blows
through the light yeah kind of like that
and then when you rub your eyes you see
those colors things everything's shaped
like that and it's whatever color it has
to be to differentiate it from another
object so nothing makes any sense an
object that might be like that's a black
table but if I'm looking at it in the
astral World it might be red a red
energy Cloud sitting on a blue floor or
blue energy you know and just things
colors change just so you can get an
image you know I mean it's not the real
color right it's just a something that
you're doing it's something that you're
doing so you can form an image of what
it is oh thank you somebody thank you
Bryce we need some money
Bryce I agree with Tom the mind is more
than just the body this is why some
seers can find water and stuff most of
those people are frauds though yeah most
of them are frauds yeah I mean there
probably is some there's more [__] that
um about our what our minds can do that
we don't understand that's for sure the
military tried to use it it's not
reliable especially under
stress it's too unpredictable it's
better to just use technology that's why
they use it and
spies yeah it's a lot more dependable
like I said humans are I'm not saying
that some humans don't have like some
cool abilities and [__] like that but
they're just too Hit or Miss yeah you
can't rely on them yeah and if you put
that person like look you must [__]
do your ability we got to save the
president that's so much performance
anxiety man [__] it's G to [__] it up
it's like you might as well just use
like [__] use an assassin or
something or an assassin or something
yeah like somebody that just yeah
something that's not going to [__] up
right that we're emotions aren't going
to get evolved right you know what I
mean cuz it's just it's too much yeah uh
Oscar is here hey what's up said Jenny
looking toned did my did gym today this
morning she was [__] looking jacked
man she got up from that [__] bench
and she way she was standing
there and never seen her look like that
say Jenny man you're looking [__]
great
man she's [__] trimming up around the
midsection [__] legs [__] I've
lost a lot of weight actually legs
getting [__] shapely and [__] arms
coming in better Tom loves that [__]
yeah yeah he loves that [__] give it a
couple more more
months actually couple you know in a
couple months you'll see a much bigger
difference but then over a period of
years each year because it's not the
same as being an old person where you're
declining every year [__] when you're
on HRT you start [__] making progress
every
year better progress than what a
teenager would
make I'm not that old I'm not worried
about it I mean I'm old but I'm not that
old it'll rebuild you yeah like the
bionic [__] woman yeah I was seeing
pictures of [__] dudes talking about
it today and [__] showed the dude he
was 62 [__] looks so much better
than me it's not even funny dude's just
[__] just
ripped [__]
62 we get people on streamate all the
time not believing how old yeah they
don't believe how old we are yeah so
that's good I like it I like it just
learn the [__] people I'm not a doctor I
don't give medical advice but just learn
the [__] get sued I don't want to get
Su all the information's out there they
don't really want you to know about it
though it's not patented medicine they
want to sell patented medicine well it's
not that hard to find I mean to be
honest you found it yeah so it's study
about hormone replacement therapies it's
fine yeah might [__] your voice up if
you're a girl but that's okay what's
that said might [__] your voice up if
you're a girl but that's okay if you're
using it [__]
postmenopause it's a good
tradeoff yeah I don't mind it doesn't
really because you know and besides when
you see these
women their voices and their bodies
match it looks nor normal cuz she just
doesn't look like a [__] dainty
flower [__] looks like a leopard
that's how they sound not talking about
Big Pro bodybuilders talking about
wellness fitness models and [__] not
well and I was saying to you earlier
like when we were watching that woman
and she was showing some of the shitty
comments she gotten about her voice and
stuff like that I'm like one I don't
know people suck and I'm just kind of
like why do you care so much about what
you don't even know that person yeah
it's like why do you care even if it was
a man why do you care like I don't
understand why she doesn't sound like a
man she doesn't but I'm like even if she
did why would you give a [__] yeah yeah
you why would you give a [__] so much
that you're like watching her video one
and then taking the time to comment yeah
exactly they want to hit they want to
hit they can't and it's very transparent
that that's the only reason because it's
like if you didn't if you weren't into
it you wouldn't be watching it or
commenting on it in the first they want
to hit and they can't hit because her
boyfriend's like an 11 yeah he's a
[__] so it's like it's just little
incels crying that's what it is
I'll show them who we're talking just
like a lot of the shitty comments on the
internet incels
crying M Bowser says if I get a blood
Poltergeist it better have blood flowing
up the walls right I mean that would at
least be
more at least you would know it was
Supernatural this one apparently like I
said they just kind of like came out and
be like man there was blood everywhere
and we don't know where it came from
which like I said I don't necessarily
think that the old people would be
pulling a prank but maybe somebody did
some [__] to them Bryce says incels
crying yeah I mean the world would be a
better place if incels would just stop
crying but [__] this this who we're
talking
about see maybe the let her turn around
that's
her yeah like I don't really I don't get
it well like I said even if I
accidentally stumbled upon a video with
some [__] that I was just like oh man
this person's an [__] I wouldn't even
bother commenting why would I bother
commenting on it I got better things to
do look at her
six-pack I actually really like her neck
tattoo
yeah she lives here in Florida and it's
fairly recent I think because I saw some
older [__] of her and she didn't have
that but I actually really like that
because it kind of looks like a high
collar like a turtleneck I'm kind of
into that it's cool she wears black
contacts is uh she's kind of a goth
chick another
pit that's her I think that's her little
gay friend or
something she comes up yeah she comes up
mess with they're always [__] goofing
around she's going to come up [__]
manhandle his
ass
yeah oh my yeah
but yeah I don't know I don't
know like I said I'm not really that
bothered about the voice but hers is
[__] twice it is a lot deeper but
it's it's still it still sounds like a
woman voice it doesn't really sound like
a man's voice yeah even if it did who
gives a [__] like I said I don't really
understand I don't understand why people
get so hung up about [__] you put her
voice next to mine that's that's
baffling to me it's baffling I'm like
you don't even know that person like why
do you why do you so much you know I
don't get it but no those dudes are
trying to hit so they're just trying to
find anything [__] wrong yeah they're
just pissing and moaning and yeah peeing
their diapers
whatever and I don't and I don't have
patience for
it I don't
know like I said once you get as old as
us you don't really give a [__] what
people think anymore especially people
like that
that would cry about somebody like that
like saying oh she looks like a man yeah
she does not look like a [__] man no
she doesn't but like I said even if she
did it was like why would you why do you
care don't know I don't know just go
ahead and shut it down Jen we've been on
for a [__] long time it's almost
midnight yeah yeah we've been on for 3
hours and 45 minutes this is a fun show
though so whenever it's Poltergeist like
I know that Tom's going to have like a I
got a lot to say about it stuff to say
about it so always makes it a good show
if you like this show the other one I
would recommend would be uh uh probably
out of body experiences and that was I
mean it's pretty old it's old I tell in
detail [__] what what my outer body
experiences were like one of them was a
near-death experience when I was in a
coma [__] motorcycle
wreck had an out of Body Experience like
a week before it happened and then had a
near-death experience kind of
like certain part of your [__] soul
knows that your time may be short
but I survived it it's like the out of-
body experience was kind of and it was
spontaneous it just did it on its own in
the barracks when I was in the
Army and the guy living with living with
me in my dorm [__] he saw it
happen he won't won't talk about it he
saw it and then uh then a week later I
had that [__] motorcycle accident and
[__] had a whole near-death
experience busted his head open yeah
[__] was at the gates of the ploma
getting ready to
recycle there's a whole [__]
welcoming Community there that all knew
me going no what's yeah they were saying
what's up you but you can't come in and
I was like I can't what are you talking
about and I'm done no you're not done so
I'm trying to go home yeah it's like
that I don't know who the other people
were they might have been other
manifestations of me I don't know other
roles that had played other games or
something I don't know if they were
me or if they were other people that I I
knew I think it might have been
me so it was like your version of Danny
yeah but there were a lot of them there
were lots of them like different ages
there like seven or eight of them okay
yeah it might have been you from the
future and the past and other dimensions
yeah one of them wasn't human one of
them was more
like Chom Manion or
neol was that girl oh okay she was
pretty but she was not human right kind
of human protohuman yeah let's call it
that yeah she's all tribal look like a
tribal
wizard like some Lord of the Rings don't
lie it's Hood you'd still
hit she was cute she was cute but she
wasn't human she kind of had a long
facial
prnus ears and [__] kind of like
chimpanzee type ears a lot of long hair
but she wasn't didn't have hair on her
face I didn't see the body and they were
made out of like welding Arc material so
I didn't really see what the skin
texture was but I knew the voice I knew
I knew the face but I wasn't allowed to
remember who it
was that was one of the ones that I
remember then it was just other ones
that were like dudes of different ages
and stuff I checked in with them all and
there was the big there was a big tall
one that was like
the like your senior advisor I don't
know if that was some kind of super ego
or if it was God or a some kind maybe
that was your guardian angel or an angel
I don't know but it was kind of like my
case manager
D yeah like in Beetle yeah
exactly in afterlife was vaguely male
but it was kind of just an elongated
humanoid form kind kind of like didn't
have a face or anything you know just an
elongated human humanoid
silhouette and I just we were speaking
telepathically you know I could hear it
I could hear its thoughts and it there
was like a emotion and voice went with
it it was all layered in at one
and I knew him he knew me and everything
we were like like old
buddies he's like you can't go back
because this and that he showed me what
it was that I had agreed to do and I was
like oh yeah yeah I forgot about
that and I was like all right you know
I'll go back and they says but you know
and they were like you'll be back soon
though blah blah and they showed me some
other stuff and and then he said you're
not going to remember any of this though
you're going to remember very few little
of this is what it was and then he said
tell people yeah he told you tell people
when you get okay I'll tell everybody
spread the word I didn't tell everybody
though now it was wasn't possible back
then right this is the closest now you
can tell the whole world you tell people
this or at least the tiny portion of the
world like yeah okay you know but
there's certain things you're not going
to be able to
remember CU I was shown things about the
future you know my future I wasn't
allowed to remember those right so um
but I when I saw him I remembered
agreeing to that like oh yeah that's the
movie I paid for that kind of [__]
like you know but you can't spoil the
ending type of deal yeah I gotta well at
least they did that no spoilers yeah so
then I said all right and I turned
around and looked and saw the damn you
saw the material
world look like The Wheel of Fortune
from the game Wheel of Fortune a disc
with a bunch of colors and as I looked
at it it was more and more intertwined
almost kind of like a damn car like a
like that oriental rug it was just a
bunch of [__] patterns and as I
looked at it more understood that that
was
like lives and things that happened in
inside time
space and I saw where I was when I
picked up like like like where you like
the groove in a record of where the song
was yeah and I zoomed into there and and
I was in the
hospital I came
back like I said that reminds me of that
c Barker book weave world yeah um it's
kind of like a record
yeah it did have a pattern you could see
but it was just showing the
representation of that so I could
understand what was happening it's not
the way it really looked it was just
symbols to describe to me how to get
back you know what I mean it's not a
disc yeah and it was outside time and
space that disc was all time and space
yeah and everything that happens in it
as a
singularity and you
know not just the Planet but the [__]
universe so it's too vast you
know yeah like you said I was trying to
show you in a way that in a more
simplified form yeah that you could like
um so I could navigate my way through
right yeah um yeah Agnes this is a dress
actually so it's purple with kind of
like a thing on it Bryce says insulting
a girl is the lamest way to try and hit
that at least be original it is very
lame yeah the thing is is [__] you
look at that [__] you look at those
dudes are [__] they're on Instagram a
lot of them that that say that these
dudes will say some sideways [__] in
Instagram and I'll go look it's like oh
let's see what this F see this D like
beautiful [__] some like 100
pound dude up in Pakistan all right with
arms like [__] little bitty
broomsticks of course he's going to be
mad well he's just mad CU she get his
ass kicked by that she look like a man
what's and one time I said yeah she
looks like a man when she's standing
next to you she's standing like to me
she looks like a woman but look like a
woman when you stand next to even more
of a woman just an ugly woman that shut
that [__] down there was a bunch of
[__] laughter people laughing yeah
yeah well like I said it's pretty
transparent like when somebody says that
kind of crap everyone's like yeah we
know what your deal is I know they think
they're being all clever and [__] like
that but it's like yeah it's all you're
just like hey I'm insecure yeah now the
world knows good job good job um Agnes
said you look really nice Jenny thank
thank you very much thank you very
much all right are you ready to shut the
show down for real getting late it's
getting late well you're the one who
kept talking I know I'm put on the show
okay you just said before tell him tell
them tell them what happened tell them
what I thought tell them what happened
all right so hopefully you guys enjoyed
the show I mean I had a good time it
went on for almost four hours damn but
yeah yeah damn damn that's show yeah all
right so we will be back Friday night
for the Sidetrack show so that's always
fun we just talk about whatever [__]
I mean about whatever more [__] than
usual um so yeah so hopefully you guys
can come and join us for that it's
always a good time so thank you
everybody for dropping by thank you for
super chats and we will see you guys
again on Friday night good night